bien chers collègues toutes mes excuses
pour ces quelques minutes de retard
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire je vous
souhaite la bienvenue pour votre
première audition devant la commission
des affaires économiques qui sera
probablement la première d'une longue
série de dictions au cours de la
législature car comme vous le savez
certainement l'agriculture est un
secteur d'activité qui suscite un
intérêt soutenu parmi nos commissaires
nous venons d'ailleurs de créer six
missions visons visant à contrôler
l'application des lois votées sous la
précédente législature et deux de ses
missions portent sur les lois relevant
de votre portefeuille d'abord la loi
visant à lutter contre la maltraitance
animale et conforter le lien entre les
animaux et les hommes et dont les
rapporteurs d'applications sont Anne
Laurence peut-elle et Daniel Simonet
et puis la loi relative à l'assurance
récolte apportée par Frédéric descrozey
et Julien Dive vous êtes devant nous
aujourd'hui pour nous présenter votre
feuille de route pour les prochains mois
les dossiers que vous aurez à traiter
sont nombreux et les attentes sont
fortes nous avons pu le constater
ensemble lors de notre visite à terre de
Jim en présence du président de la
République le 9 septembre dernier dans
le département du Loiret l'un des
départements de la région Centre que
nous connaissons bien vous et moi et qui
abrite notamment la plaine de la Beauce
qui assume totalement ses fonctions
productrices nourricières et
exportatrice à cette occasion le chef
d'État a annoncé des axes de la future
loi d'orientation et d'avenir agricole
que vous devriez nous soumettre au cours
de l'année 2023 nous allons évidemment
vous interroger sur le contenu de chacun
de ces axes qui constitue autant de
défis à relever à savoir l'orientation
et la formation la transmission des
exploitations l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs la transition et
l'adaptation face au changement
climatique dont les effets se font
fortement sentir cette année en
particulier mais pas seulement
s'agissant de la gestion de l'eau
Emmanuel Macron l'a dit très clairement
je le cite je veux que dans les
prochains mois on puisse déployer et
mettre en oeuvre les projets qui ont été
traduits dans le varen je veux qu'on
puisse aller au bout des bassines des
retenues colinéaires comment
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre cet
engagement un autre sujet préoccupe les
agriculteurs et les élus depuis
plusieurs années déjà et conditionne la
réussite de toutes les politiques
agricoles et par conséquent la
préservation de notre souveraineté
alimentaire je veux parler évidemment de
la question de la juste rémunération des
agriculteurs et donc du prix d'achat de
leur production dès le mois de juillet
notre commission s'est penché sur
l'application de la loi egaline 2 sur le
rapport de Nicole le P et Grégoire de
Fournas nous rapporteur ont notamment
regretté que dans les filières soumises
à la contractualisation obligatoire
celle-ci ne soit pas mise en oeuvre pour
une grande majorité de producteurs vous
avez vous-même monsieur le ministre
dénoncer les pratiques des grandes
enseignes engagées dans une course au
prix bas qui ne garantit pas la marge
des producteurs
comment comptez-vous assurer
l'application des lois et Gallim pour
fixer les prix conforme à la justice
économique et permettant de préserver
l’avenir de notre agriculture sans plus
attendre monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je suis très
heureux de retourner à l'Assemblée
nationale dans des fonctions nouvelles
qui sont celles pas nouvelles
récentes mais quand même depuis quatre
mois je suis au en poste au ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire pour devant vous évoquer des
sujets qui sont à la fois des sujets de
préoccupation continue de cette
commission et puis des sujets de
préoccupation qui sont les sujets de
préoccupation d'actualité et donc vous
dire en
plusieurs points ce qui est la feuille
de route qui est la mienne et la volonté
qui l'amène à ce poste avec un certain
nombre de déclinaisons qui ont parfois
leur traduction législatives et parfois
d'autres moyens de l'action et de levier
de l'action publique je le fais d'autant
plus avec plaisir que je sais d'abord la
préoccupation qui est la préoccupation
de cette commission sur ces sujets et
puis deuxième élément c'est que je
considère à la fois évidemment dans les
lois qui pourraient être appelés à que
vous auriez appelé à délibérer à
l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi dans le
débat que nous avons à noué avec la
société je pense que le rôle que vous
avez comme parlementaire est un rôle qui
me semble éminent et donc voilà quelques
éléments que je voulais vous livrer
d'abord
attirer votre attention même si parfois
ça paraît anecdotique sur l'intitulé
nouveau de ce ministère puisqu'il
s'appelle ministère de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire et qui
montre la volonté qui est la nôtre
de faire en sorte que nous puissions
faire face aux défis de la souveraineté
alimentaire et les épisodes et la crise
ukrainienne vient de nous leur après
devient de nous la crise sanitaire est
venue d'abord souligner l'importance
stratégique de notre agriculture avec
une mobilisation sans faille des femmes
et des hommes qui consomment qui
concernent l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire les producteurs les
transformateurs les distributeurs pour
éviter une rupture d'approvisionnement
majeure et pour garantir un accès à
l'alimentation il faut toujours assurer
la continuité de cette chaîne la guerre
en guerre en Ukraine nous rappelle quant
à elle que l'alimentation que nous
concevons depuis 60 ans en européen
comme un levier pour bâtir la paix et la
solidarité peut devenir une arme la
crise ukrainienne elle vient démontrer
au fond que un certain nombre d'acteurs
je pense aux présidents de la Russie ont
décidé de se servir de ce levier pour
peser sur la géopolitique armes
énergétique armes alimentaires comme
deux outils de stratégie géopolitique et
donc ça vient remettre au coeur du sujet
la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire et on y reviendra peut-être
de maintien d'un certain nombre de
paysages et donc c'est aussi dans ce
cadre là de la qualité de nos
productions de la diversité de nos
productions et c'est aussi dans ce cadre
là qu'il faut penser la souveraineté
alimentaire le cadre est donc posé bâtir
notre souveraineté et pour cela
accompagner nos agriculteurs face aux
défis immédiat comme dans les
transitions à la certains oppose parfois
les nécessités de transition à la
question de la souveraineté moi je pense
que l'un et l'autre se nourrissent et
qu'on ne pourra assurer ni l'un ni
l'autre si chacune des parties n'est pas
remplie la souveraineté d'une part et la
capacité à nous adapter aux grandes
transitions qui sont devant nous c'est
d'ailleurs dans ce cadre que nous avons
travaillé pour finaliser la PAC dès ma
prise de fonction à travailler immense
avait déjà été réalisé par mon
prédécesseur dont je salue l'action au
ministère de l'Agriculture et j'en
profite pour dire que la France a fait
partie des sept premiers pays qui ont vu
leur plan stratégique nationale validée
ce qui plutôt une exception dans les
processus de la PAC
la volonté qui était la nôtre était de
faire en sorte que les agriculteurs
disposent du cadre dans la saisonnalité
qu'elle est leur c'est à dire plutôt au
mois d'août quand on sait la pratique
des assolements pour pouvoir faire face
au nouveau défi de la PAC ce PSN c'est 3
Ambitions principales que nous avons
porté au niveau européen une ambition
clairement économique avec des aides aux
revenus des agriculteurs qui sont
confortés la France a choisi de
maximiser l'enveloppe à louer aux aides
couplées tout en rénovant celle-ci dans
un objectif de création de valeur dans
les territoires et de souveraineté
alimentaire au travers de l'augmentation
des soutiens aux protéines végétales de
la réfonte des aides bovine ou encore de
l'instauration de l'aide aux petits
maraîchage et cette ambition économique
est également affirmée avec le ciblage
des aides vers les filières et les
territoires les plus fragiles je pense
notamment à l'élevage extensif dans les
zones à handicap incluant évidemment les
montagnes une ambition environnementale
puisque notre PSN s'attache à encourager
à une diversité renforcée des systèmes
de production à accompagner l'autonomie
de production et inciter au renforcement
de la résilience du secteur cherchant la
sobriété en un temps à ce titre les
mesures de la PAC notamment les corps
régimes sont particulièrement mobilisés
en faveur de la préservation des
prairies de l'implantation et du
maintien des haies de la diversité des
assolements et du développement de
l'agriculture biologique avec un
objectif de 18 % de la surface agricole
à horizon 2027 et puis enfin une
ambition sociale avec la revalorisation
des soutiens aux jeunes agriculteurs
pour soutenir le renouvellement des
générations
l'introduction d'une conditionnalité
sociale sur les aides de la PAC mise en
oeuvre des 2023 est le droit à l'erreur
qui est un élément déterminant pour moi
pour améliorer les relations entre les
agriculteurs et leur administration
c'est une nécessité il faudra
attentivement éveiller parce que parfois
on pose le principe
on pose le principe de ce droit à
l'erreur après il faut encore faut-il
qu'il rentre en application tout cela
s'inscrit dans le cadre des avancées
obtenues sur la réciprocité des normes
au cours de la présidente française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne nous avons
posé ces questions ces enjeux ses
principes dans le débat européen et nous
l'avons fait de manière à ce que la
réflexion engagée le soit de manière
irréversible on a ainsi obtenu un
consensus sur la nécessité de renforcer
la cohérence entre le pacte vert la PAC
et la politique commerciale qui était un
oubliée si je peux dire de ces
réflexions vers des systèmes
alimentaires durables l'adoption par le
Conseil des conclusions sur l'engagement
de l'Union européenne en faveur d'un
Codex Alimentarius qui permet de
construire une stratégie d'influence
européenne et qui constitue une
application pratique du principe de
réciprocité il convient désormais de
rester pleinement mobilisé parce qu'il y
a toujours des effets de d'élastique
dans ses affaires pour faire en sorte
que ce que nous avons posé comme cadre
ce à quoi la Commission a répondu qu'il
était possible effectivement de
d'intégrer ces clauses de réciprocité
soit bien à l'oeuvre dans les futurs
discussions européenne c'est un enjeu
d'ailleurs majeur pour moi y compris
dans la transition écologique en France
et en Europe c'est d'ailleurs dans
l'optique de protéger nous agriculteurs
qu'un autre chantier pour notre
souveraineté avait été lancé sous le
précédent quinquennat et vous en avez
été pour beaucoup les témoins je pense
celle je pense évidemment la question du
revenu agricole et des deux lois qui se
sont succédés la loi égal 1 puis la loi
également 2 c'est pour moi la mer des
batailles pour accéder à la souveraineté
parce qu'il faut sans cesse le rappeler
si nos agriculteurs ne peuvent pas vivre
de leur travail alors nous n'aurons plus
la capacité à produire pour nourrir en
qualité et en quantité sur le sol
français la loi égal ligne 2 a permis
d'enrayer la dynamique des flationnistes
et destructrice de la valeur avec des
hausse moyennes avant crise Ukraine de
3,5% pour les fournisseurs de la grande
distribution
malheureusement la crise ukrainienne est
vue impacter évidemment vous le savez
très fortement le processus et dès le
mois de mars ainsi que exceptionnel
puisque normalement nous étions sur un
rythme manuel ainsi que exceptionnel de
négociations s'est engagée
ensuite aller à flamber de l'inflation
pour vous donner simplement quelques
chiffres 6500 tarifs de fournisseurs ont
été renégociés ou sont en cours de
renégociation pour certains produits
comme le bœuf ou la volaille il y a eu
jusqu'à 5 révisions de tarifs
fournisseurs et c'est bien logique
contenu de la fluctuation des cours des
prix et des matières premières nous
allons être attentif à ce que la
contractualisation continue de se
développer elle a été mise en place des
manières anticipées des devines 22 pour
les ports et les bovins et pour le lait
de vache et de brebis et doit l'être au
1er janvier 2023 pour les autres
filières la contractualisation c'est la
base
de la souveraineté alimentaire parce
qu'elle permet de stabiliser les choses
la loi Gallim n'est probablement pas
parfaite vous me le direz probablement
mais tout se règle pas d'ailleurs dans
les lois je le disais encore ce matin
dans une autre intervention et la
nécessité aussi que le jeu d'acteur se
mette en place de manière correcte et
vous serez appelé certainement à me
faire à la fois des remarques et des
propositions en ce sens cette loi
s'applique depuis peu je rappelle
qu'elle a été votée en novembre 2021
dans un contexte particulier celui des
événements Ukraine je le disais tout à
l'heure ce qui sont du bouleverser et en
bouleverser la philosophie s'étend tout
état de cause d'un filet de sécurité
indispensable qui fait preuve de son
efficacité qui a permis de sauver de
très nombreuses exploitations ce n'est
pas pour mon satisfaire c'est simplement
pour dire que c'est une première étape
et il nous faudra tirer les conclusions
de ce qui s'est passé au moment de la
crise ukrainienne dès lors que les
choses seront un peu plus stabilisées le
gouvernement continue d'être pleinement
mobilisé avec mes collègues de Bercy
pour peser dans les négociations pour
mettre en lumière les difficultés pour
mettre en lumière les pratiques qui ne
sont pas conformes à l'esprit et à la
lettre de la loi mais aussi parfois à
l'esprit et pour essayer de faire en
sorte que les choses avancent on veut
pour exemple la mobilisation qui a été
aussi la vôtre d'ailleurs et la nôtre
sur la question du prix du lait pour
faire en sorte que la rémunération soit
plus en adéquation avec la réalité des
coûts la difficulté est parfois dans la
transformation aussi va d'abord première
difficulté c'est de faire en sorte que
tous les distributeurs s'alignent
deuxième difficulté c'est de faire en
sorte que dans la chaîne de production
dans la transformation les hausses
proposées se retrouvent bien aussi chez
les producteurs laitiers sinon nous
aurions un risque évidemment de
décapitalisation on y reviendra
peut-être j'en viens maintenant au sujet
tout aussi essentiel pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire sur lequel
votre commission et l'assemblée vont
être associées globalement celui du
renouvellement des générations vous en
avez parlé monsieur le Président le
président de la République a présenté le
9 septembre dernier le contour de la loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricole qui
vous sera soumise
ces 10 dernières années 100 000
exploitations ont disparues dans les 10
prochaines la moitié des agriculteurs
seront en âge de partir à la retraite ce
seront donc plus 200 hommes et femmes
qui nous nourrissent par leur travail
dont l'activité pourrait cesser et donc
l'enjeu de la transmission est un enjeu
majeur l'enjeu clair pour garantir notre
souveraineté agricole et alimentaire il
faudra garantir le renouvellement il
nous faudra bâtir un système tenable et
viable pour nos agriculteurs dans ce
contexte de Brand grand bouleversement
on n'est pas simplement dans un effet de
nécessité de renouvellement de
génération on a aussi une réflexion à
portée à peser que je comportais au
travers de ces lois et des débats
préparatoires que nous aurons sans doute
ensemble d'installer des jeunes ou
parfois d'ailleurs des moins jeunes en
tout cas ceux qui veulent s'installer
dans ces métiers dans un système dont on
se dit que dans le dérèglement
climatique qui est le nôtre dans le
dérèglement économiques et parfois le
nôtre ils tiennent dans la durée
évidemment c'est une transmission
transition et c'est pas une transmission
reprise classique en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'il faudra le faire à mon
sens il s'agit de bâtir avec le monde
agricole impact de renouvellement et de
confiance
autour de quatre piliers l'orientation
et la formation la transmission
l'installation et la transition et
l'adaptation au changement climatiques
dans cette perspective le président de
la République aderz est déjà annoncé que
pour consolider notre enseignement
agricole il serait le fond de
l'innovation de pédagogique serait doté
de 20 millions d'euros et puis il y
aurait dans le cadre d'un de
intitulé entrepreneur du vivant 400
millions d'euros qui seront mis en place
pour soutenir les installations des
jeunes afin des accompagner à la fois
dans les transitions indispensables et
délicieux sur plusieurs années la charge
que représente une installation je pense
évidemment parfois la charge foncière il
y a la question d'ailleurs aussi dans
cette affaire-là de l'accès aux foncier
et la question aussi de la charge
capitalistique qui ont fait peser
parfois sur des jeunes qui ne peuvent
pas le faire et qui est autant qui sont
qui constituent autant de freins à
l'installation des jeunes les 6
prochains mois vont permettre une large
concertation sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets afin que cette loi
puisse présenter au premier semestre
2023 à votre assemblée et se
construisent et je le dis pas par effet
de tribune se construisait avec vous
avec l'ensemble des acteurs des
territoires en plat signifiant
territoire par territoire et au fond
aussi filières par filière les
évolutions structurelles et les
objectifs que nous souhaitons assigner à
l'agriculture française la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est aussi permettre à nos
agriculteurs de tenir face aux crises
qu'il est touche et à travers le soutien
portait leur permettre de passer le cap
de situation difficile et Dieu sait
qu'ils en ont passé difficile et qu'il y
en a encore de difficile afin qu'il
puisse continuer à produire mais aussi
les accompagner pour qu'ils enclenche
des évolutions durables sur leur mode de
production je pense en premier lieu
parce que ça reste d'actualité à la
réponse que nous avons apporté face à
l'augmentation des prix des matières
premières liées à la gare en Ukraine ce
sont 639 millions d'euros qui ont été
déployés entre les dispositifs d'aide à
l'alimentation animale et de prise en
charge des cotisations sociales et je
sais que dans vos circonscriptions vous
êtes nombreux à être sollicité par nos
agriculteurs sur les augmentations de
charges je reviendrai juste après ce
plan de résilience ce n'est pas
seulement une réponse à une situation
d'urgence c'est aussi des perspectives
tracées à long terme il a été décidé
dans le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
de permettre la valorisation des achats
sur la campagne en cours récolter à
l'été il s'agissait évidemment de
continuer à produire de produire plus
mais aussi de produire différemment en
donnant à nos agriculteurs la capacité
de mettre en culture ses jachères en
céréales en néologie ne ou en protéines
végétales c'est d'ailleurs le sens aussi
du plan protéine digital dont je vais
vous dire un mot qui vise à réduire
notre dépendance aux importations c'est
aussi une affaire de souveraineté des
pays tiers et améliorer l'autonomie des
éleveurs pour face aux questions
d'approvisionnement
enfin ce plan de résilience s'accompagne
aussi d'un soutien à l'investissement à
travers de France 2030 ce sont ainsi 300
millions qui vont permettre de financer
les investissements dans les dépenses
d'infrastructure de fonciers
d'immobilier pour les brevets les
licences pour l'achat d'équipements et
de machines des dépenses
d'industrialisation de dépenses
d'amélioration énergétique et
environnementale des outils de
production et des dépenses de prestation
de conseils qui sont associées parce
qu'on sait combien l'accompagnement et
la prestation et la nécessité de conseil
va être grande dans les grandes
transitions qui sont à l'oeuvre notre
objectif n'est pas seulement de faire
face à la crise en Ukraine il faut
évidemment le faire et ce que nous
tâchons de faire c'est surtout de
renforcer le secteur agricole et
agroalimentaire notamment dans ce
contexte de la guerre et de poser les
jalons d'un modèle durable viable pour
chaque agriculteur afin de bâtir j'y
reviens à notre souveraineté alimentaire
j'en viens plus rapidement vous allez à
sanitaires n'ont pas que ils ne soient
pas important
qui touche nous agriculteurs et nos
territoires je pense à la bruxellose à
la tuberculose à la salmonellose et
j'aurais peut-être l'occasion d'y
revenir mais surtout à l'influenza
arrière s'agissant des filières
volailles sur l'influence de sa vie à ce
sont plus de 1,1 milliards d'euros qui
ont déjà plus de 100 millions qui sont
engagés qui ont été programmés pour
faire face aux conséquences sanitaires
économiques de l'épidémie je suis
insiste sur ce chiffre parce que un
milliard et de rose c'est à mettre en
corrélation du chiffre d'affaires de ces
filières qui est de 7 milliards d'euros
donc c'est un plan de soutien
extrêmement massif qui a été porté
non seulement un plan de soutien pour
gérer la crise mais aussi un plan de
soutien pour avoir une feuille de route
qui permet de penser le modèle d'élevage
de volailles avec la prééminence et là
il l'existence quasi endémique désormais
manifestement de la grippe aviaire et
donc c'est à la fois un modèle en
transition qu'on a voulu soutenir et en
même temps répondre aux sujets de la
crise alors on a une stratégie vaccinale
qui est en train d'être en
expérimentation dont on aura les
résultats je le dis au passage décembre
janvier qui permettra dès lors que les
résultats seraient avérés
de faire en sorte que nous puissions
déployer avec un sujet qui sera un sujet
de niveau européen c'est que cette si le
vaccin était
qualifié si je peux dire pour répondre à
cette grippe aviaire de ce de se
garantir aussi que ça ne vienne pas
freiner la capacité d'export de ces
filières parce qu'on sait qu'elles sont
pour certaines puissamment
exploitatrices bâtir notre souveraineté
alimentaire je le disais en introduction
c'est également penser l'avenir de notre
agriculture comme une part de notre
avenir en tant que nation et je voudrais
vous parler du sujet évidemment de
l'alimentation et du bien-être animal
puisqu'il s'agit aussi de trouver de
faire écho est-ce que peuvent être les
demandes sociétales sur le sujet de
l'alimentation je voudrais aborder trois
points le sujet des projets alimentaires
territoriaux il s'agit à travers de cet
outil de mieux articuler l'offre et la
demande dans le cas dans le cadre de
France relance près de 80 millions ont
été mobilisés pour la mise en place de
ces projets au 1er avril 2022 plus de
370 projets sont labellisés par l'État
et l'objectif d'au moins un projet
alimentaire territorial par département
est atteint et nous serons même
largement au-delà donc et nous devons
continuer sur cette lancée c'est un
intérêt de dialogue territorial c'est un
intérêt de valorisation des productions
locales et c'est intérêt aussi en termes
de rémunération deuxième point le chèque
alimentation durable c'est un engagement
qui a été pris dans la continuité de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
président de la République la réaffirmé
en disant la pertinence du dispositif
comme la première ministre ce n'est pas
seulement d'ailleurs je le dis un enjeu
pour nous agriculteurs c'est un enjeu de
société c'est un enjeu de solidarité
c'est un enjeu qui doit permettre à des
personnes qui ne peuvent pas accéder
d'accéder à une alimentation durable et
de qualité c'est avec cette ambition que
je poursuis le travail initié avec le
ministre le ministre et le ministère de
la Santé et des Solidarités puisque
c'est dans son périmètre notre objectif
est donc bien de définir un dispositif
qui répondent pleinement aux objectifs
de la convention citoyenne et c'est cet
objectif sur lequel nous devons avancer
alors je ne vous dirai pas qu'il n'y a
pas des écueils des difficultés des tas
contingence qui sont posées mais c'est
pas parce que c'est compliqué qu'il faut
y renoncer mais simplement on a un
certain nombre de sujets sur laquelle
nous consultons nous et nous essayons de
nous forger une opinion pour voir par
quel circuit pour quel type de produit
pour quel type de public il faut que
nous avançons et c'est donc avec cette
volonté là qu'on avancera avec mon
collègue des solidarités nous pourrions
par exemple pour nous donner que
quelques exemples imaginez que les
projets alimentaires territoriaux
constituent un vecteur
nous pourrions de la même manière et à
titre d'exemple sans être exhaustif
faire le lien avec l'application des
objectifs de la loi égalim en
restauration collective offrir des repas
de qualité à tous les enfants scolarisés
avec sans doute une vocation aussi
pédagogique à ce travail et il me semble
que ça pourrait être des pistes qui
pourraient être pour être accompagnés ou
creusé dans le cadre de ces dispositions
c'est en tout état de cause dans cet
esprit que nous souhaitons avancer et
apporter des réponses solides à la que
nous remettrons à la première ministre
conformément à sa demande troisièmement
j'aurais rappelé suite à l'arbitrage de
la première ministre le que le ministère
de la souvantho le souveraineté
alimentaire sera bientôt police unique
sanitaire c'est un enjeu majeur et le
ministère est pleinement mobilisé nous
sommes attendus par nos concitoyens nous
travaillons avec les services de Bercy
pour à la fois assurer dans de bonnes
conditions des transferts de personnels
et surtout assurer dans de bonnes
conditions les missions qui doivent
d'être dévoluer à cette politique unique
sanitaire sur le bien-être animal vous
en avez parlé monsieur le Président des
avancées qui ont quand même été réels je
pense au plan de filière répondant aux
attentes sociétales je prends je pense
au plan lutte contre des animaux de
compagnie je pense au plan abattoir avec
plus de 180 abattoirs et des à la fois
pour la modernisation économique mais
aussi pour la modernisation sur le sujet
du bien-être animal je pense au
renforcement des contrôles et des
inspections et la création d'une force
d'intervention sur les abattoirs je
pense à la fin de la castration à vif
des porcelets depuis le 1er janvier 2022
je pense à la fin du voyage des pouces à
mâles à partir
à partir du 1er janvier 2023 et donc
tout cela ce sont des avancées qui sont
à mettre au crédit de la mandature qui
vient de s'achever et aussi des
agriculteurs et des filières qui se sont
engagés il y a toujours aussi derrière
je lis la question de la rémunération et
de qui au fond paie à la fin les
avancées que nous souhaitons il me
semble que c'est un élément important et
puis dire qu'on a inventé aussi sur un
certain nombre de projets
d'investissement pour la biosécurité via
France relance 90 millions pour près de
3000 projets des achats sont attendus
sur le bien-être animal je considère
pour ma part que si des échéances sont
attendus au niveau européen c'est bien
au niveau européen qu'il faut les
traiter et pas forcément au niveau
national parce que sinon nous
commencerions à introduire des
distorsions qui ne paraissent pas
acceptable y compris avec le concept de
souveraineté alimentaire mais il y a des
échéances qui arrivent à chair assez
rapidement sur le bien-être animal et
qui nous permettront d'avancer sur ces
sujets je voudrais conclure par la
question évidemment de la transition
écologique et de la date d'adaptation au
changement climatique
le ministère sera au coeur de ces
réformes et de cette volonté de
planification de transition par la
planification tout ceci passe par le
financement de la recherche et
l'innovation en agronomie et
l'investissement dans la troisième ou ce
qu'on appelle la troisième révolution
agricole la France a déjà engagé au
niveau national des plans massifs
d'investissement notamment au travers de
France relance et France 2030 plus de 4
milliards d'euros sont où seront
investis pour financer des solutions
durables innovantes notre agriculture
pourra notamment s'appuyer sur la
sélection variétale le biocontrôle la
robotique robotique et le numérique mais
pour moi l'innovation ne se limite pas
l'innovation technique ou technologique
pour moi l'innovation c'est une aussi
une innovation des pratiques une notion
de la formation j'en disais un mot tout
à l'heure une innovation dans le modèle
c'est donc l'ensemble des inondations
qu'il faudra mobiliser et ça nécessitera
aussi sans doute des moyens au niveau
européen latin des objectifs et donc
conditionné à l'émergence d'un cadre
commun permettant un déploiement mousse
massif de ces solutions pour faire face
à ces défis qui sont immenses ces défis
sont nombreux pour faire il s'agit
d'abord de faire face à l'intensité à la
violence des épisodes climatiques de
plus en plus fréquents et de plus en
plus prégnant sur le monde agricole vous
avez cette année des gens qui ont été
frappés par le gel par la grêle et par
la sécheresse sur les mêmes
exploitations et qui donc donne le
sentiment moins d'alcool dans une
impasse de production et avec des
difficultés d'adaptation qui sont
grandes parfois l'actualité est donc
immédiate c'est l'épisode de sécheresse
nous on a réuni sous mon Egide plusieurs
comités sécheresse à la fois pour
prendre la mesure regardez les mesures
de régulation qu'il faut les prendre
avec mes collègues du MTE on sait déjà
qu'on a un certain nombre de
conséquences sur cette sécheresse on a
déjà développé un certain nombre de
dispositifs notamment pour favoriser
les éleveurs qui sont dans une situation
de difficulté de trésorerie pour
alimenter leurs bêta ce qui sont obligés
de faire dès le moment où je vous parle
ou même parfois un peu plus tôt encore
que le moment où je vous parle
mobilisation des calamités agricoles
avec une volonté d'accélérer
le calendrier le calendrier normal c'est
un versement au mois de mars avril la
volonté c'est d'accélérer autant que
faire ce peu le calendrier pour que les
aides soient versées dans un calendrier
soit conforme aux besoins de trésorerie
des exploitations et qui les incitent
pas à des capitaliser mobilisation
exceptionnelle des avances de la pacte
c'est 1,5 milliards de plus qui seront
versés au 16 octobre ça permettra aussi
d'apporter de la trésorerie et je
n'insiste pas mais évidemment les
dispositifs plus classiques de
dégrèvement des cotisations sociales et
automatiques et du dégrèvement sur le
foncier bâti je dis juste un mot sur le
foncier bâti le dispositif est très
connu il est empirique j'allais dire il
est très ancien ce que je constate avoir
eu des échos avec un certain nombre
d'entre vous d'agriculteurs c'est que
une difficulté de ruissellement si vous
permettez cette expression parce que
c'est le propriétaire qui touche il
n'est pas souvent très rompu à savoir
qui est le bailleur et donc il y aura
peut-être une réflexion à portée pour
regarder comment quand on fait ce
dégrèvement il va bien en destinataire
final qui doit être évidemment me
semble-t-il l'agriculteur et puis
l'obligation sur les de déroger un
certain nombre de dispositifs pack parce
qu'il y avait pour certains
l'impossibilité à prodiguer ou à
pratiquer plutôt des semis enfin nous
devons objectiver les situations
individuelles des agriculteurs pour
regarder dans le dispositif qu'on je
suis en train de définir devant vous de
faire en sorte qu'on regarde s'il y a
pas des trous dans la raquette et qu'il
y a pas des situations qui seraient
encore pire que celles que nous avons
sous nos yeux lavable l'adaptation
changement climatique c'est aussi deux
points le premier c'est l'assurance
récolte j'aurais saluer la rapidité avec
laquelle le texte a été délibéré et voté
au Parlement mars 2022 avec un objectif
potentiel donc c'est une réforme pour
moi structurelle le deuxième pilier
c'est la question des usages de l'eau
et à l'intérieur il y a deux sujets le
premier c'est l'évolution des pratiques
l'évolution des variétés ça ça peut être
par la recherche
l'évolution de la seulement dans un
certain nombre de cas et puis le
troisième sujet le deuxième sujet pardon
c'est évidemment
la question de l'accès à l'eau je
voudrais m'arrêter sur cette question
quelques instants d'abord rappeler une
évidence qu'il est parfois bon de
rappeler c'est que l'histoire agricole
est vieille comme le monde et l'histoire
agricole c'est une affaire de d'accès à
l'eau
et de rappeler que quel que soit la
production agricole on a toujours besoin
d'eau alors les moments on a besoin
d'eau ne sont pas toujours les mêmes
pour produire il faut de l'eau et donc
il faut absolument qu'on essaie de
résoudre cette question deuxième élément
c'est le GIEC qui le dit ce n'est pas
moi c'est on n'a pas à faire un volume
d'eau en diminution à terme dans le
modèle A2 degrés on a affaire à une
arythmie
de la plus géométrie donc c'est
l'arithmie ça veut dire des périodes de
grande séchage mais ça veut dire aussi
des périodes de grandes inondations et
donc il faut qu'on travaille sur le
sujet là avec ça qu'on regarde
un des secteurs entiers qui vont être en
difficulté
géographiquement je dirais des filières
et deux un sujet d'arithmique qui fait
qu'il faut qu'on essaie de travailler
sur la question des usages pour faire en
sorte que parfois ça puisse servir pour
lutter contre les inondations parfois ça
puisse servir pour l'irrigation parfois
ça puisse servir tout ça peut se
combiner pas dans la même temporalité
pour les soutiens des tirages parfois ça
puisse servir ça a été le cas pour
l'alimentation en eau potable et parfois
parce que c'est un sujet qu'on abordera
peut-être rapidement aujourd'hui pour
lutter contre les incendies parce que
c'est un élément on a vu les contraintes
qui ont pu poser cette année dans une
forme de montée en latitude du risque
des incendies et donc il y a ces leviers
là qu'il faut faire le varen de l'eau a
tracé une voie à la fois de dialogue de
méthodes et d'un certain nombre de
projets la question c'est désormais que
nous déroulions les projets de
conformément à ce qu'ils doivent être je
le dis les choses assez simplement
j'ai vu un certain nombre d'actes de
vandalisme de destruction d'ouvrages sur
des projets qui étaient des projets qui
avaient passé tous les caps des recours
et des dispositions légales qui sont
nécessaires et normales dans la cadre de
construction de projet ça n'est pour moi
pas acceptable il faut simplement qu'on
arrive à poser les trucs sujets dans les
territoires de dire et d'essayer de
faire comprendre que c'est un partage de
l'eau qu'on va faire et qu'on a besoin
d'eau et que l'eau quand elle est
prélevée par les agriculteurs elle n'est
pas prélevée pour un bien privé les
prélever pour un bien commun qui n'est
pas le moindre des biens c'est celui de
pouvoir s'alimenter
quand un agriculteur prélève de l'eau
ils prélèvent pour faire de
l'alimentation végétale ou de
l'alimentation animale par rebond et
donc c'est aussi comme ça qu'il faut
penser le sujet de l'eau en agriculture
et c'est un élément très important
j'ajoute qu'il faut sans doute
explorer des pistes d'abord les ouvrages
qui sont plus mobilisés qui peuvent être
des ressources importantes
parce que il y a plus de structures
agricole et peut-être qu'ils peuvent
être mobilisés et deux quelque chose sur
lequel on est là c'est aussi édifié de
ce qui s'est passé cet été de la
réutilisation des eaux de station nous
sommes le pays qui réutilise le moins
les eaux de stations enfin l'un des pays
qui lui réutilise le moins en Europe je
vous donne deux chiffres en France 1%
des autres stations sont réutilisées en
Italie c'est 14 en Espagne c'est presque
10 je nous parle pas de la situation
israélienne qui est particulière mais
qui est à 80% donc on a besoin d'avoir
un évolution doctrine sur ces sujets là
parce que là aussi il y a dans certains
territoires ce n'est pas la solution
partout mais des capacités en eau qu'on
pourrait mobiliser qui serait qui serait
importante je finis juste par un sujet
parce que ça fait partie de mon
périmètre que la question des incendies
de forêts qui sont un élément évidemment
important de l'actualité qu'on a connu
mieux par les mêmes difficultés
sécheresse canicule
pour moi il y a trois sujets qui sont
sur la table la sujet d'une
acculturation plus grande y compris
géographique des sujets de défense de la
forêt contre l'incendie
traditionnellement sud-ouest et
traditionnellement sud-est les
événements de l'été nous ont montré que
cette
les feux de forêt pouvaient être très
haut monter en latitude que ça posait la
question à la fois des moyens de lutte
que ça posait la question de
l'appropriation de ces outils dans des
latitudes qui n'avaient pas l'habitude
de penser y compris leur peuplement
forestier dans cette condition là
premier sujet deuxième sujet ça pose la
question concomitamment du rôle des
forêts dans la captation de carbone et
des difficultés dans laquelles se
trouvent les massifs forestiers du fait
du dérèglement climatique
en moins de 20 ans les forêts on capte
deux fois moins de carbone qu'elle ne
capter
non pas parce qu'à moins de surface
forestière mais la surface
correspondière cache une réalité c'est
que l'accroissement forestier beaucoup
plus faible contenu du dérèglement
climatique et des épisodes de canicule
là où on avait deux à 3 %
d'accroissement en masse et donc en
stockage carbone on est plutôt alors je
suis dans les grandes masses à un 5 par
an d'accroissement et donc ça ça pose un
problème de l'adaptabilité de nos forêts
et de l'adaptation des essences qui sont
plantés face aux dérèglements
climatiques et ça c'est un élément qui
me paraît important il y aura évidemment
la question de la reconstruction des
forêts il y a aussi la question sans
doute du modèle de financement de la
reconstruction des forêts je rappelle
d'ailleurs parfois ça fait l'objet de
polémique que 75% du massif forestier
français c'est un massif forestier
d'ordre privé
et que pour près de millions d'hectares
c'est des forêts qui font moins de 15
hectares des propriétaires qui disposent
de moins de 15 hectares ce qui pose des
problèmes de mobilisation de la
ressource d'organisation y compris du
renouvellement forestier
pour faire en sorte que y compris ces
petits ces petits îles au forestiers et
donc nous aurons un travail à faire dans
le cadre du de la suite des travaux qui
ont déjà été menés pour faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des massifs forestiers
compris dans les plus petites dimensions
puissent être mobilisées à la fois pour
leur capacités productrices mais aussi
pour leur capacité à stocker du carbone
il me semble que c'est un élément
important je voudrais juste saluer
d'ailleurs sur le sujet là par
importante compris les agriculteurs j'en
suis à ma dernière page monsieur le
Président là par importante compris les
agriculteurs dans la défense des forêts
contre l'incendie et la défense contre
les incendies
nous avons pris des dispositions à
postériorer pour pouvoir les indemniser
mais à la vérité sont intervenus si on
leur demande sans qu'ils viennent nous
demander d'être indemnisés j'aurai salué
la mobilisation qui a été celle et que
vous avez vu dans un certain nombre de
territoires des recruteurs qui eux-mêmes
contraints dans les questions de
sécheresse on mobilisés qui leur donne à
lisaient qui leur matériel pour apporter
un appui et un soutien important je dis
à la à votre assemblée que il serait pas
inintéressant que dans le dispositif de
vigie de sentinelle
et de défense de la forêt contre
l'incendie on essaie de regarder ce que
peuvent être les apports par exemple du
monde agricole dans un cadre qui soit
moins spontané alors la spontanéité a du
mérite mais c'est pas mal aussi que ça
puisse être organisé je trouve que c'est
c'est à salué c'est important et c'est
parce qu'ils sont un maillon essentiel
on va formaliser un plan on va
formaliser un plan aussi de résilience
sur les questions forestières avec des
éléments de réponse qui sont apportés
par le gouvernement et par le Président
de la République dont les semaines qui
viennent voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire non pas en quelques mots parce que
ça ce sera une figure de style voilà un
certain nombre de points que je voulais
mettre
sur la table je dis simplement que le
cap que j'ai pour moi est un cap simple
c'est le cap de la souveraineté la
souveraineté c'est la production la
souveraineté c'est la transition la
souveraineté c'est la rémunération l'un
souveraineté c'est l'installation la
souveraineté c'est l'accès aux foncier
c'est tous ces éléments là sur lesquels
il faut qu'on travaille dans les mois et
les semaines qui viennent parce que dans
les moments que nous traversons nous
ferions une grande erreur à désarmer sur
la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire et donc c'est bien la
feuille de route que je souhaite que
nous essayons de tracer au niveau
national mais évidemment au niveau
européen parce que je pense que le
moment que nous traversons a peut-être
réveillé quelques consciences merci
merci monsieur le ministre pour ce
propos introductif alors je n'ai pas
coupé les 32 minutes
par respect par intérêt aussi parce que
vous dites et passionnant mais là il va
falloir avancer donc je rappelle le
principe sinon on est là toute la nuit
ensemble monsieur le ministre mais on
aura deux occasions de se voir je vous
propose le même exercice que d'habitude
donc chaque orateur de groupe à 4
minutes pour interroger monsieur le
ministre vous avez jusqu'à maxi 3
minutes et à 3 minutes je coupe pour
laisser minimum une minute de réponse à
Monsieur le Ministre par contre je vous
le dis tout de suite monsieur ministre
vu le timing et vu les 32 minutes
d'introduction à 4 minutes je couvre
vraiment donc vous m'en voudrez pas
d'être sévère sur le timing à partir de
ce moment je fais à mon honorable
j'avais compris que j'avais un temps
illimité donc je me suis arrêté quand
même
nous commençons tout de suite avec
Monsieur Pascal Lavergne du groupe
Renaissance c'est à vous merci monsieur
le Président bonjour monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre c'est un
immense plaisir que de vous recevoir
pour la première fois devant notre
commission des affaires économiques à
titre personnel et je pense que cela est
partagé par de nombreux parlementaires
vos premiers pas vos premières prises de
position sont encourageants et vont à
mon sens dans le bon sens ces dernières
années l'agriculture est au cœur vous
l'avez dit dans votre propre introductif
des crises et des tensions la crise
sanitaire du covid les crises diverses
crises commerciales aujourd'hui une
crise géopolitique et évidemment une
crise ou un épisode effectivement de
crise climatique l'agriculture comme la
rappeler récemment Jean-Marc Jancovici
ne fait que 2% du PIB pour autant elle
nourrit 100% des bouches et elle occupe
deux tiers du territoire à titre
personnel j'aime à dire qu'il n'y a pas
de génération spontanée dans le frigo ni
sur les étagères de la cuisine pourtant
pourtant l'agriculture fait l'objet
d'attaque et de déversement de mensonges
ou de contre-vérité sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment monsieur le ministre
j'estime que ce quinquennat et vous
l'avez je pense déjà introduit
simplement doit être celui de la
transformation agricole transition des
pratiques agricoles transition
énergétique aussi puisque l'agriculture
il prend sa part et enfin parce que on
en parle que trop peu l'amélioration
plus que substantielle des conditions de
vie des agriculteurs il n'y aura pas de
souveraineté et je vous l'avais dit
votre attachement cette souveraineté je
le suis aussi extrêmement attaché à ça
c'est la souveraineté alimentaire sans
agriculteur il n'y aura pas
d'agriculture sans une amélioration
notoire des revenus et des conditions
d'exercice également du métier et donc
de l'attractivité de ce métier soyons
juste avec ceux qui nous nourrissent
parce qu'il n'y a pas plus altruisme pas
plus généreux que le métier
d'agriculteur monsieur le ministre pour
cette transformation que vous appelez de
vos vœux que nous appelons de nos vœux
quelle loi quelle réforme envisager vous
en avez déjà brossé un certain retrait
et sous quel calendrier et avec quels
efforts éventuellement budgétaires
devant nous les réaliser
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre j'ai
déjà beaucoup répondu à un certain
nombre de vos interrogations donc merci
de vos mots je vais rebondir juste sur
un point parce que je vous avais évoqué
cette question c'est la question du
dialogue avec la société je pense qu'on
a besoin dans les assemblées au
gouvernement sur les territoires de
faire comprendre ce que le métier
d'agriculteur de faire comprendre ce qui
est le sujet de la souveraineté et des
contingences que ça impose et de faire
comprendre qu'en quoi les transitions ne
sont pas aussi simples à faire qu'à dire
et y compris dans la revalorisation du
métier et le renouvellement des
générations et y compris dans la
nécessité des transitions que nous avons
à faire si nous n'arrivons pas à poser
ça sur la table je considère c'est un
frein immense donc je serai unise
agriculture soucieux du dialogue et
soucieux aussi de faire comprendre ce
qui se passe et les révolutions qui sont
nécessaires dans le monde agricoles qui
sont complexes voilà ce que je voulais
vous répondre il y aura d'autres
occasions mais sur le point particulier
ça me permettait de répondre là dessus
super merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur Grégoire de Fournas
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre nomination au ministère
de l'Agriculture intervient dans un
contexte où 200 fermes disparaissent
chaque semaine en France et seulement
une exploitation sur trois trouver un
repreneurs nous assistons par ailleurs à
une désespérance qui s'est durablement
installé dans les campagnes et qui se
traduit par le chiffre effrayant d'un
agricole du suicide en agriculteur tous
les deux jours
l'agriculture paye en réalité le lourd
tribu de vos politiques ultralibérales
et libre-échangistes imposé par l'Union
européenne cette dernière laisse nos
agriculteurs en concurrence déloyale
avec la terre entière quand elle ne
l'organise pas elle-même avec la
multiplication des traités de
libre-échange l'Union européenne a cassé
la jambe de notre agriculture et lui
propose une béquille poursuivie survivre
cette béquille ce sont ces fameuses
subventions que vous aimez chers
collègues à rappeler régulièrement en
oubliant de préciser que cet argent ne
vient pas de planche habillé caché dans
les caves de Bruxelles mais de la poche
des Français l'Union européenne n'a donc
aucun mérite à distribuer des
subventions avec l'argent des Français
d'autant qu'elle le fait extrêmement mal
lors des multiples manifestations
d'agriculteurs on ne peut on ne peut
qu'être frappé par cette revendication
extrêmement sensée qui ne ces exprimer
nous ne voulons pas des aides nous
voulons des prix sur nos produits des
prix pour nos produits c'est mettre pas
une grande distribution qui ne cesse de
matraquer nos agriculteurs c'est aussi
les protéger contre une concurrence
étrangère des loyale monsieur le
ministre je vais évoquer un point mais
il y en a d'autres la loi égaline II
votée par notre Parlement souverain
prévoit des dispositions très claires
concernant l'étiquetage notamment sur
l'utilisation du drapeau français
pendant réserver l'utilisation sur les
emballages qu'a des produits dans
lesquels dans lesquels l'ingrédient
principal est français ce qui est quand
même la moindre des choses lors de la
mission d'évaluation de la loi egalim 2
dont j'étais co rapporteur au mois de
juillet j'ai questionné vos services
pour savoir pourquoi plus de six mois
après la promulgation de la loi vous
n'aviez toujours pas publié le décret
d'application la réponse fut que cela
n'était pas prévu car c'est décrées
serait aussitôt attaqué au Conseil
d'État car contraire au texte européen
ma question est simple que comptez-vous
faire pour que la loi votée par le
Parlement soit enfin appliquée et que
les producteurs français soient protégés
ma seconde question concerne chaque
alimentaire annoncé par madame la
Première ministre j'ai demandé au mois
de juillet à vos services il était prévu
que ce chèque soit fléchés vers les
productions françaises la réponse fut
que cela était impossible en raison là
encore des textes européens que quand
vous donc faire pour que ce chèque
alimentaire ne dégrade pas une balance
commerciale déjà mal en point et qui
contribue à la souveraineté alimentaire
que vous ne cessez d'évoquer
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
d'abord c'est toujours plus commode de
faire des caricatures que d'essayer de
poser les choses dans la complexité de
ce qu'elles sont première élément
tout le monde est d'accord avec l'idée
que la rémunération vous tout et c'est
bien les sujets principal d'ailleurs je
l'ai posé dans mon propos liminaire que
la rémunération c'est un élément
fondamental d'abord de la dignité du
travail que porte les agriculteurs et
deux de la du contrat qui est passé avec
la société
ne pas oublier que les fondements de la
pâte ont été fondés sur un avec une
évolution désormais mais on était quand
même fondé sur la volonté qu'on soit en
capacité d'être souverain d'un point de
vue alimentaire et de à des prix qui
était les plus acceptables possibles et
les plus bas possible
quand c'était ça le contrat qui avait
dans la PAC
quand vous en parlez aux agriculteurs
les acteurs ne sont pas et je reviendrai
sur les bémols qu'on peut y ajouter
parce qu'il y a certains points sur
lesquels on peut ajouter des bémols les
agriculteurs ils ont toujours défendu la
PAC ça jamais été la question pour eux
oui je vais répondre à vos questions
mais si vous me l'aviez laissé plus
d'une minute je vous aurais répondu plus
longuement alors les deux questions les
questions non mais ne faites ne faites
pas parce que je veux dire par là s'il
faut pas faire dans l'anti-européen
parce que c'est pas le sujet qui est
posé alors les questions et pourquoi j'y
vais pour parce que nous sommes dans un
cadre européen que nous avons des règles
de commerce que nous avons des
producteurs que nous avons des
producteurs qui exportent à l'extérieur
des frontières françaises la filière
port la filière volaille elle reste et
que donc il y a besoin dans le contexte
européen d'avoir des règles qui ne font
pas de la distorsion entre nous
qu'est-ce que je dis aux éleveurs de
porcs qu'est-ce que je dis aux éleveurs
de volailles qui exportent à l'extérieur
de nos frontières et donc on a besoin
d'adapter des dispositifs alors on peut
toujours penser on peut s'extraire des
cadres européens mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça peut fonctionner la réponse que
je vous fais merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame Bénédicte taurine pour le groupe
la France insoumise je vous remercie
donc dans un premier temps monsieur le
je souhaite vous interpeller au sujet
d'une problématique qui touche tout
particulièrement ma circonscription
puisque sur les 70 ours présentes dans
les Pyrénées il y en a une cinquantaine
en Ariège la présence de ces animaux
induits des dégâts sur les troupeaux et
des tensions entre les divers usagers de
la montagne avec cet été un point de
crispation majeur lié à l'interdiction
de les farouchements d'autre part des
élus s'interrogent quant à leur
responsabilité en cas d'accident c'est
pourquoi j'ai à cœur Monsieur le
Ministre de vous inviter à venir dans
mon département à faire un état des
lieux de la situation et plus
globalement afin d'aborder divers sujets
touchant à leur ruralité donc j'espère
avoir une réponse favorable de votre
part
monsieur le ministre
par principe la réponse est favorable à
un déplacement et je prends l'invitation
volontiers le sujet que vous posez ces
sujets de la prédation globalement
d'ailleurs il y aura peut-être d'autres
questions sur le sujet avec en
particulier le sujet le sujet chez vous
qui est le sujet ours qui est tout à
fait visible vous avez évoqué des
décisions qui ont été des décisions
d'interdiction des farouchements qui
n'étaient pas la volonté du gouvernement
puisque c'était évidemment les mesures
qui avaient été prises puisque le loup
étant strictement de protéger il y a pas
de mesure le l'ours pardon est en
strictement protégé il y a pas de mesure
de régulation et donc les seules mesures
possibles sont les mesures des
farouchements le disposition a été
attaqué en justice et nous avons perdu
en justice et donc il faut qu'on
retrouve un chemin et des dispositions
pour faire en sorte qu'on ne laisse pas
parce que c'est ça la difficulté
principale qu'on ne laisse pas les
agriculteurs les éleveurs en particulier
en l'occurrence
dans un sentiment d'impuissance la leur
est globalement de la puissance publique
sur ces sujets là il faut qu'on arrive à
se dire quand même qu'à un moment
l'élevage sous la contrainte de la
prédation recule
il faut le dire il faut que ça soit
compris dans la société c'est valable
pour l'ours c'est valable pour le loup
qui sont les deux sujets principaux et
donc je vais porter y compris la semaine
prochaine au niveau européen pour le
coup plutôt sur le loup mais globalement
qu'on est comporte une réflexion sur
comment on peut combiner parce que il
est une chose de dire autour d'une table
on peut combiner on peut faire cohabiter
les deux l'après les prédateurs les
grands prédateurs et les activités
d'élevage il y a des situations où se
manifestement ça n'est pas le cas donc
on a besoin de trouver un chemin en
particulier sur le sujet de les
farouchements parce que c'est le sujet
principal dans l'ours et je sais
l'attention que ça produit dans les
territoires j'en ai parfaitement
conscience mais je viens je viendrai le
constater moi-même j'en ai parfaitement
conscience mais j'essaye aussi d'abord
de trouver des solutions par rapport au
sujet précis que vous venez de poser qui
est sujet de les farouchements
alors comme on a de l'avance vous avez
la possibilité de continuer madame
sur concernant la grippe aviaire vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement le constat l'an
dernier c'est 16 millions de volailles a
battus dans des conditions parfois
insupportables et tout fait dans des
bâtiments par exemple suite à l'arrêt
des ventilations
enfoui dans des fosses à la ferme la
clustration et la battage des animaux ne
peut pas être la seule réponse de l'État
face à cette maladie
donc allez-vous continuer à ne pas faire
de distinction entre les divers élevages
et poursuivre les abattages généralisés
où y a-t-il d'autres solutions et
comment les éleveurs peuvent répondre à
la demande des consommateurs qui pensent
acheter des produits notamment les oeufs
produits en plein air ou des poulets bio
alors que durant plusieurs mois c'est
voilà ils sont enfermés et que l'élevage
ne correspondent donc plus au cahier des
charges en vigueur ce ministre 50
secondes simplement pour vous dire non
mais pas de problème simplement pour
vous dire à date les meilleures mesures
et c'est pas nous qui le disons c'est
lancés
et moi je mets au fil à lancer les
meilleures mesures que nous connaissions
c'est les mesures parfois d'abattage et
évidemment de claustration ça pose les
problèmes que vous dites en particulier
sur les volailles qui portent le label
plein air avec des dérogations qui sont
faites mais qui posent un problème de
modèle à terme deux éléments de réponse
le premier c'est qu'on a aussi dans le
plan de résilience à vierge implant de
dédensification d'un certain nombre
d'élevage et ça ça a été porté y compris
par la filière et puis deuxième élément
de réponse j'ai demandé à linds
pour le printemps prochain de pouvoir me
dire si dans certains types d'élevage y
compris ceux que vous évoquez la mesure
de claustration est une mesure qui est
de nature à dégrader notre capacité à
avoir une réponse sanitaire ou peut ne
présenter suffisamment peu de risques
pour le faire donc on a bien ça sur la
table c'est bien identifié pour essayer
de trouver une réponse sur ce sujet qui
est tout à fait identifiée merci
beaucoup monsieur Julien dive pour le
couplet républicain merci Monsieur
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
hérité d'un portefeuille qui a désormais
une nouvelle terminologie souveraineté
alimentaire et c'est sur ce point que je
voudrais insister quand on prend le
contexte une balance commerciale
agricole qui est déficitaire si on
extrait les vins et les spiritueux 50%
des poulets consommés en France qui sont
importés 40% des légumes 60% pour les
fruits des surfaces de verger qui
réduisent chaque année une industrie
agroalimentaire qui a qui subit des
pertes de rentabilité vous avez évoqué
la question aussi des exploitants qui
prennent de l'âge et qui sur lesquels il
va falloir travailler sur la question de
la succession et trans
et dans ce contexte à date aujourd'hui à
date nous avons des producteurs de
pommes de terre qui récoltent
aujourd'hui leur culture avec des
rendements inférieurs de 20 à 50% selon
ce qu'ils aient pu irriguer ou pas qui
doivent stocker dans des bâtiments de
stockage dédié avec des coûts d'énergie
qui subissent des hausses de 570% et qui
donc du coup vont devoir déstocker
rapidement une filière endive qui est
aux abois pour les mêmes raisons en
termes de coûts énergétique une filière
betterave qui a dû mettre à la sucre qui
a dû anticiper plutôt que prévu la
récolte avec des rendements moindres
aussi parce qu'ils anticipent les
sucriers anticipent une envolée des
coûts d'énergie pour la rentrée pour la
le début d'année prochaine donc moi
j'aimerais par rapport à cet enjeu la
souveraineté alimentaire vous interrogez
monsieur ministre sur trois points le
premier c'est votre avis sur la
stratégie ferme tout fort qui on sait
risque d'avoir un impact négatif sur la
production agricole européenne votre
avis sur la suppression des taxes
antiques dumping à l'échelle européenne
parce qu'on l'a aussi une vraie
problématique sur les approvisionnements
d'engrais pour les prochaines cultures
et les prochaines livraisons et la
dernière question concerne le revenu
vous l'avez raison de rappeler que le
revenu est à sacralisé la loi est Gallim
a prévu de manière expérimentale le SRP
le dispositif de SRP + 10 c'était
expérimentation arrivera à terme au
printemps 23 un rapport doit être mis ce
n'est pas encore fait j'aimerais savoir
ce qu'il en sera de la suite de ce SRP +
10 merci monsieur le ministre
sans être exhaustif évidemment mais
d'abord sur SRP plus i je commence par
ça
a été d'ailleurs l'objet de quelques
dialogues ou discussions sur les médias
sur un certain nombre d'opérateurs de la
distribution qui remettait en cause de
SRP pudis qui intuitivement de donne
plutôt l'impression que c'est il y a un
intérêt au SRP + 10 pour dire les choses
deuxième élément évidemment il y aura il
y aura nécessité d'un rapport qui mais
je qui permette de détayer ce que je dis
au-delà de l'intuition qu'on a du fait
que ça intéresse dans le projet de loi
égali mais dans le disposition et de
regarder comment cette expérimentation
pourrait être prolongée évidemment
produira les éléments qu'il faudra pour
qu'on ait un rapport qui soit étayé sur
cette question là mais évidemment plutôt
favorable deuxième point
farm to fork
farm to fork c'est 6 mois avant la
guerre en Ukraine et ça pose sur la
table le principe
d'une tendance qui est une tendance à
moins 15% de la production européenne je
pense qu'il faut qu'on en débattre pour
être très direct avec vous au niveau
européen parce que on doit quand même on
peut pas passer des événements comme
ceux qu'on traverse
on peut sérieusement pas se poser la
question des moments qu'on traverse sans
se poser la question de la stratégie
alimentaire dès lors que ça devient une
arme il faut se poser la question de
est-ce qu'on est dans la stratégie forme
tout fort que à mon avis ça peut être la
seule ligne directrice dans la stratégie
femtoforc de faire en sorte que nous
soyons en capacité à tout point de vue à
tout moment
d'accéder à une alimentation pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens c'est bien
la base j'ajoute qu'il faut aussi se
réfléchir dans Farm tofuck à la capacité
à traiter la question de nos frontières
or l'Union européenne de capacité à
alimenter je comprenais moins bien votre
question sur la suppression des taxes
anti-imping c'est la demande de
suppression de taxes innumping pour
accéder
Bruxelles a supprimé les taxes sont-ils
dumping sur les engrais à sauter l'an
dernier en 2021 aujourd'hui on a ce qui
a contribué d'ailleurs à
l'explosion des coûts de ces engrais
azotés sauf qu'aujourd'hui on a une
vraie problématique à la fois à la ferme
pour payer cet accent ces engrais azoté
puisque ils deviennent trois quatre fois
plus élevés qu'avant et en plus de ça il
y a une vraie problématique de livraison
voilà quelques secondes monsieur
ministre un sujet qui est d'abord
d'assurer l'approvisionnement pour la
saison 2023 et là on a besoin qu'il y
ait du flux parce que c'est quand même
ça le sujet et deux on a un deuxième
sujet et c'est peut-être cela sur cela
qu'il faut qu'on insiste un sujet de
reconquérir une souveraineté en termes
d'engrais azoté en minéral mais aussi la
transition du minéral vers l'organique
donc c'est sur ces deux poids pieds là
qu'il faut avancer merci beaucoup
monsieur Martineau pour le modem
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher Marc cher collègue je vous
remercie pour votre présence avec nous
ce jour et j'ai été très heureux de vous
accueillir dans notre Sud Sarthe et je
connais votre attachement à nos valeurs
j'ai souhaité vous interroger à propos
d'un sujet d'actualité tenant
directement renforcement de souveraineté
alimentaires puisqu'il s'agit du
développement des retenus colinaires
même si vous y avez en partie répondu
tout à l'heure
puisque il s'agit du développement des
retenus colinaires à même d'apporter
donc une réponse face aux difficultés
voir l'impossibilité d'irrigation de
certaines cultures agricoles en effet le
dérèglement climatique et l'absence de
pluie au cours du printemps et bien sûr
pendant l'été font que nos cultures ont
souffert et souffrent encore aujourd'hui
du manque d'eau sans opadvis ce qui est
vrai pour l'homme les tout autant pour
notre agriculture les limitations voir
les interdictions d'irrigation suite au
niveau très bas des rivières ont
provoqué de graves pertes dans les
vergers et dans les cultures maraîchères
comme dans d'autres cultures agricoles
les jeunes arbres ne sont pas certains
de redémarrer au printemps suivants
ainsi au cours des commisses agricoles
dans la Sarthe plusieurs agriculteurs
sont venus vers moi se demandant s'il
devait continuer de planter des vergers
et investir dans les cultures
maraîchères sans eau il est sans doute
difficile de les y encourager j'ai
l'exemple d'une retenue colinéaire en
Indre-et-Loire créée en 1990 permettant
à une douzaine d'agriculteurs d'irriguer
leur culture cette retenue de 40 000 m²
environ avec une zone végé
de 20 000 m² autour
a permis de recréer une zone de
biodiversité avec interdiction des
activités humaines telles que la pêche
et la navigation si bien que la zone
humide a été déplacée agrandi et
accueille de nombreux espèces animales
et végétales à ce jour dans la Sarthe et
malgré les avancées très intéressante en
France dans la continuité du varen de
l'eau les procédures pour encourager à
la création de nouvelles retenues
colinéaires ne sont semble-t-il pas
assez contenu et donc demeure ainsi FISE
insuffisamment exploitée monsieur le
ministre cher Marc pourriez-vous nous
aider à réaliser ce type de réserve
permettant le stockage de l'eau
hivernale et ainsi assurer à nos
agriculteurs la possibilité de sauver
leur travail et notre nourriture je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
trois éléments de réponse rapide le
premier vous avez mis en exergue la
capacité pour des ouvrages à avoir
une multifonctionnalité au fond multi
multi intéresse si je peux dire y
compris un intérêt biodiversité deuxième
élément vous avez tout à fait raison de
dire et ça rejoint la question en
quelque sorte ça fait écho à la question
de jeudi c'est la question de la
souveraineté c'est la capacité sur les
territoires à pouvoir être sécurisé par
exemple sur la question de l'eau pour
pouvoir produire il y a des territoires
s'il y a pas d'eau il y en aura plus
d'arboriculture et après on verra nous
expliquer qu'on manque de pommes ou
qu'on manque de producteurs de pommes
pour ne prendre que cette filière que
vous connaissez bien puisque c'est celle
que vous connaissez très bien dans votre
département de la Sarthe troisième
élément il faut qu'on arrive à avoir des
procédures qui soient plus lisible pour
les porteurs de projets
et dont on essaie d'accélérer les
process dès lors qu'on est dans des
process qui sont des process bien normés
il faut quand même qu'on puisse
accélérer les processus parce que on
court derrière le dérèglement climatique
et ça serait une erreur en termes là
aussi de souveraineté de ne pas se poser
des questions c'est pas valable il y en
a pas des besoins partout mais à chaque
fois qu'on se pose un projet de
développement de territoire agricoles il
faut se poser la question de l'accès à
l'eau
merci beaucoup il reste un peu de temps
vous étiez réagir juste dire voilà que
justement si ça peut accélérer les
procédures puisqu'on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de dossiers qui reviennent avec
des avis défavorables sans qu'on
connaisse les raisons de ses avis des
favorables je vous remercie
très bien monsieur potier du groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre heureux de vous
avoir été dialogué avec vous aujourd'hui
la France a perdu 650 000 têtes de
bétail en 4 ans 24% des éleveurs en dans
les dernières décennies c'est
certainement le sujet majeur de
souveraineté et d'équilibre
agroécologique de notre pays tout le
reste un peu de la littérature si on
sauve pas l'élevage notre modèle
agricole français dans ce qui va de
vertueux est perdu pour ça il faut un
rééquilibrage des prix je vais y revenir
mais il faut aussi qu'on traverse sa
crise présente avec une hausse des
matières premières qui ne peuvent pas
aujourd'hui répercutés dans la
transformation dans la distribution
est-ce que dans ce contexte là il n'y
aurait pas été judicieux de provoquer un
nouveau cycle de négociation de la
compagnie de l'imposer pour sauver pour
le lait et pour la viande nos élevages
et ne pas accélérer cette catastrophe
annoncée de d'un désespoir qui se nous
chez les adverbes vous avez évoqué la
transmission et la transition monsieur
le ministre le président de la
République a annoncé reportage du
foncier je voudrais dire aujourd'hui que
s'il n'y a pas de partage du foncier à
côté du portage il n'y aura ni
transmission ni transition sans
installation il y aura pas
d'agroécologie il y aura pas d'avenir
d'agriculture et c'est aujourd'hui le
dérèglement de la concentration du
foncier qui est le principal obstacle
plus que le portail donc du portage lui
mais pas sans partage enfin sur la
question du revenu egalim 1 et Gallim 2
s'il y a également 3 il faut qu'on soit
dans le dur le dur c'est le rapport de
force du jeu des acteurs tels que la vie
ne tourne plus autour du pot et ce cette
question c'est le renforcement des
associations d'organisation de
producteurs et des capacité de gérer
volume et prix et c'est la mise à mal
aujourd'hui du cinéma du phénomène de
quasi oligarchique de ceux qui
concentrent l'achat de la production et
de la distribution sur les phytos on a
vécu un mandat de faux plat êtes-vous
prêt à réactiver tels que l'avait promis
des stages généraux de l'alimentation un
processus d'affranchissement progressif
de la chimie une sortie vers le haut
avec de nouvelles solutions et pour ça
réactiver et cofito au bon niveau y
compris dans la phase de concertation
avec tous les partis prenantes deux mots
pour terminer sur la précarité je me
réjouis que vous ne confondiez pas la
fin et les moyens comme on l'a trop fait
parfois le chèque alimentaire n'est pas
je ne le pense pas n'est pas la solution
par contre la précarité est un vrai
problème et j'aime votre idée de
reprendre le faisceau des possibles pour
répondre à cette question de
l'alimentation santé pour tous dans
notre pays pour l'eau il y a une
question capitale c'est la question de
la gouvernance tout le reste c'est que
des bonnes intentions qui va gouverner
qui va décider starbitrage entre les
différences d'usages de l'eau dans quel
périmètre à cette question là vous
n'avez pas répondu et j'attends vos
réponses merci
oui je pense que c'est un sujet central
alors d'abord faudrait saluer ça fait
quoi ce que dit Eric Martineau à ce qui
s'est passé cet été il faut quand même
saluer la qualité du dialogue qui s'est
instauré ça toutefois était un dialogue
rugueux mais entre les services de
l'État les agriculteurs les autres
usagers de l'eau et chacun a pris ses
responsabilités et on a pas vu y compris
dans les contrôles au FB je le dis au
passage des agriculteurs qui n'est pas
respecté les règles c'est pas là qui ont
été le non-respect des règles faut le
dire quand même et donc je pense que
l'échelle départementale qui est un des
produits du varen de l'eau pour
dialoguer est un échelle importante mais
dans la question de la construction des
ouvrages dans la question de la gestion
des ouvrages dans la question de leur
finalité il y a évidemment la question
de la gouvernance et vous avez raison
vous me permettez de le dire parce que
c'est une question sur lequel il faut
puisqu'ils ont des finalités multiples
il faut qu'il y ait une gouvernance qui
permet de tracer cette question là ça
sera pas simple mais il faudra le faire
parce que toute façon il va bien falloir
partager cette eau et c'est un élément
évidemment essentiel sur le chèque
alimentaire j'en en dis pas plus mais
oui il faut pas confondre la fin et les
moyens et l'objet il faut toujours
revenir à ce qu'avait dit la convention
citoyenne c'était l'objectif et que nous
partageons de ce chèque alimentaire sur
egalim 3 ou 2 ou 3
d'abord 1 il faut qu'on laisse égal lime
de fonctionner et en tirer les
conséquences de vous m'appeler ça fait
partie un nouveau cycle de négociation à
vrai dire le nouveau cycle normalement
c'est un cycle annuel comme vous le
savez le cycle de négociation il est en
continu depuis la guerre en Ukraine tous
les jours il y a des passages des
hausses de tarifs et donc on a une vraie
difficulté et donc c'est ça il faudra
qu'on voit ça je répondrai tout à
l'heure sur la question du foncier merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur Thierry
Benoît pour le groupe horizon
et bien
monsieur le ministre je vais continuer
dans le même registre de que mon
prédécesseur qui concerne le revenu
agricole on a travaillé dans le dernier
mandat sur les négociations commerciales
à l'unanimité les industriels ont
dénoncé ont dénoncé les mauvaises
pratiques du secteur de la grande
distribution avec les négociations
déflation et une pratique qui se nomme
les pénalités dites logistiques monsieur
le ministre êtes-vous prêt à interdire
la pratique des pénalités logistiques
qui vise purement et simplement à
détruire de la valeur c'est une
invention du secteur de la grande
distribution qu'est-ce qu'on dirait si
les agriculteurs appliquaient des
pénalités logistiques à leur
fournisseurs ou à celui qui vient
collecter le lait deuxième point depuis
la fin du mandat de Michel Barnier le
début du mandat de Bruno Le Maire
c'est-à-dire depuis une petite quinzaine
d'années
s'agite régulièrement le spectre de la
contractualisation monsieur le ministre
vous venez de présenter votre projet
stratégique national à Bruxelles donc à
l'Europe est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
accorder des moyens financiers
supplémentaires à partir de la politique
agricole commune aux organisations de
producteur et aux associations
d'organisations de producteurs parce que
ça n'est ni les interprofessions ni les
Chambres d'agriculture ni les syndicats
agricoles qui négocieront pour le compte
des agriculteurs je vous remercie qui
négocieront les prix je m'entends bien
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur député d'abord merci parce que
vous avez beaucoup suivi ces questions
notamment sur egalim le premier sujet
sur sur
c'est la question des pénalités
logistiques c'est vrai que c'est une
spécificité française parfois avec les
mêmes enseignes
centrale d'achat ça me permet de
rebondir aussi sur ce qu'a dit Dominique
côtier la concentration existe partout
mais c'est chez nous qu'on a le plus
grand problème entre la grande
distribution et la ville la filière
allemande donc on a un sujet de pratique
et de jeux d'acteurs et on est le seul
pays du monde avoir été obligé de faire
une loi également à égalim 2 et comme
poser la question des game3 donc il y a
quelque chose qui qui dysfonctionne dans
notre modèle deuxième élément j'ai
demandé à la DGCCRF de documenter ce que
vous dites il y a eu une forme de
moratoire qui s'est créée au tout début
de la crise ukrainienne pour mettre loin
les questions des pénalités logistiques
je trouvais que c'était une bonne
pratique je vois que c'est désormais un
outil de régulation pour retrouver des
marges sur le dos de l'amant donc j'ai
demandé à documenter ça surtout qu'avec
la DGCCRF nous avons travaillé à des
règles de conduite sur ce que devait
être des pénalités logistiques
une fois qu'on va avoir posé ces
problèmes là soit les pratiques changent
soit les questions que vous posez n'est
pas illégitime
mais c'est quand même terrible que dans
ce pays on soit obligé à chaque fois
qu'on a un sujet qui devrait être régulé
naturellement qu'on soit obligé de
passer par du règlementaire ou de la loi
et donc j'interrogerai les distributeurs
d'abord parce que quand vous regardez
les pratiques sont pas les mêmes de l'un
à l'autre
il y a des distributeurs aujourd'hui qui
pratiquent quasiment aucune pénalité
logistique
et d'autres qui sont massivement à avoir
recours aux pénalités logistique et ça
c'est quand même une question ça veut
donc dire que c'est pas une question de
je sais pas quoi de modèle économique ou
d'endroits où il y aurait plus de
pénalité qui justifierait ça veut dire
que c'est un choix dans une stratégie
économique et c'est donc là-dessus qu'il
faut travailler donc les recours les
sanctions de cas échéant et troisième
élément après on va voir si les acteurs
se mettent en ligne par rapport à ce que
je dis troisième élément sur la question
sur la question du PSN effectivement on
a on permet la mise en oeuvre de
programme sectorielle pour quasiment
toutes les filières on est à 0,5 dans le
PSN tel qu'il est versé à 3% au maximum
dans le cadre du plan dans la durée et
la question que vous posez c'est de
pouvoir regarder l'accès
désorganisations de filière des
organisations spécialisées assez donc
l'enveloppe peut être augmenté on va
travailler pour regarder si on pourrait
d'une façon ou d'une autre donner droit
à votre demande parce que c'est un
élément important effectivement de la
structuration c'est désormais ouvert
dans le PSN c'est une bonne nouvelle
après il faut regarder mon en dialogue a
sûrement avec vous les meilleures des
moyens pour intégrer ces filières là
après il y a des sujets de
réglementation mais on peut essayer de
regarder comment on peut y travailler
merci beaucoup madame lère nous du
groupe écologiste oui merci monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminaires nous sommes
effectivement au carrefour de multiples
crises la crise du climat de la
biodiversité puisque pour produire de
l'alimentation il nous faut des sols en
bon état un climat et puis de l'eau et
également et puis la crise du covid a
mis en exergue l'explosion de la
précarité alimentaire qui avec
l'inflation va aller bon train puisque
plus d'un Français sur quatre ne peut
pas se nourrir aujourd'hui en France à
sa fin
enfin la guerre en Ukraine a aussi mis
en exergue non résilience ou la question
de la souveraineté alimentaire
je reviens puisque il y a une semaine
ont eu lieu vous l'avez évoqué également
dans vos propos liminaires le rôle et la
place des collectivités territoriales
notamment à travers les Pat
il y a eu les deuxièmes Assises
Nationales de la transition alimentaire
et agricole à Nantes avec certaines
recommandations qui ne me paraîtrait
sans de porter à votre connaissance
notamment au sujet de la précarité
alimentaire
mais aussi de la précarité des
agriculteurs et notamment la question
foncière qui paraissent absolument
essentielle dans la période à venir mais
face aux moyens des collectivités et des
Pat j'ai envie de dire que le nerf de la
guerre est quand même sur la politique
agricole commune que vous avez également
évoqué et c'est 9 milliards
d'investissements annuels qui
constituent effectivement notre outil
central de planification de la
transition agroécologique pour s'adapter
aux changements climatiques et pour
permettre véritablement à nos paysans
d'être accompagnés vers une agriculture
qui protège l'environnement pour créer
de l'emploi et puis également pour
offrir une alimentation durable et de
qualité à tous nos patriotes or le
compte rendu final de votre plan
stratégique nationale pour cette
nouvelle Pâques et largement insuffisant
tant sur le climat que sur la
biodiversité que sur le plan social
malgré d'ultime arbitrage progressiste
obtenu par les organisations paysannes
et citoyennes intitulées pour une autre
bac que je salue ici pour leur
engagement le cap général donné à notre
politique agricole reste inadapté au
défi qu'il nous reste à relever quelques
exemples le régime concernant les
Chorégies vous accordez certains niveaux
supérieurs à la rémunération du bio par
rapport au HSE néanmoins dans la
révision du cahier des charges de cette
dernière demeure encore largement
insuffisante pour justifier sa
valorisation et puis le PSN ne considère
pas de rehausse de budget pour les
mesures agroal environnementales et
climatiques qu'encouragent pourtant la
Commission européenne ou notre stratégie
éco phyto2+ pour accélérer la sortie des
pesticides
sur la question des aides à
l'installation vous l'avez évoqué elle
est absolument fondamentale dans la
période que nous vivons nous déplorons
le décalage entre les ambitions
affichées là par minimale du budget à
louer le renouvellement générationnel et
pourtant un pré-requis indispensable à
la production alimentaire donc en l'état
actuel ce plan nous permettra nid
d'atteindre des objectifs prévus par le
pacte vers européen ou la stratégie
nationale bac carbone nid d'assurer la
résilience de l'agriculture
ok juste une question est-ce que sur le
PSN la révision est-ce que vous vous
engagerez à le discuter également devant
notre assemblée notre présentation
nationale
vous avez posé les termes du débat qui
peut avoir lieu entre nous sur PCN juste
un mot les arbitrages sont les
arbitrages j'assume tous les arbitrages
y compris les arbitrages finaux et c'est
pas la pression des uns ou des autres
c'est juste qu'on essaie de trouver un
équilibre qui nous paraissait
intéressant deux sur la question du bio
j'ai du mal à être soumis à la pression
vous voyez sur ce sujet deuxième élément
sur la question du bio c'est pas
seulement les ailes à la conversion faut
faire dans la crise qu'on nous
traversons aujourd'hui ukrainienne le
problème c'est que il y a un problème de
marché pour le bio donc il faut qu'on
travaille avec les agriculteurs bio pour
pas les mettre dans des situations de
faire des conversions et de se retrouver
à se déconvertir comme c'est en train de
se faire sur le lait parce qu'il y a pas
la rémunération donc posez la question
de la conversion sans poser la question
de la rémunération me semble-t-il serait
une erreur et par ailleurs pour ce qui
est de notre question si je comprends
bien c'est est-ce que je viendrais
devant vous pour faire un état de
un point d'étape pour régulier sur le
PSN aucune difficulté pour regarder
parce que d'abord on aura des besoins
d'ajustements il me semble normal que ça
soit d'ordre public si je peux dire
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur jumelles pour le groupe GDR
bon en 4 minutes il faut choisir donc
moi le député du Pays de Brest je vais
choisir mon angle c'est celui de la
souveraineté alimentaire sur le lait et
l'élevage la souveraineté alimentaire et
bousculée on arrive à un point de
bascule monsieur le ministre vous le
savez fin ça fait des années que la
question du prix du lait mis sur la
table les lois égaliment 1 2 avaient des
bonnes intentions avec des objectifs
généraux généreux mais force est de
constater qu'on sait pas donner les
moyens de la loi qui régule de la loi
qui protège et les crises que nous
traversons montrent que le marché n'est
pas en capacité de réguler de protéger
de préserver ni notre souveraineté ni un
prix rémunérateur couvrant les coût pour
nos agriculteurs donc je veux relayer
avec force l'intervention de mon
collègue potier quelle mesure d'urgence
pour mettre sur la table une inversion
des rapports de force avec la grande
distrib avec les grands transformateurs
qui chez moi payent le livre de lait 38
centimes alors qu'on le retrouve dans
les rayons à 78 centime comment si les
marges différemment c'est vraiment le
sujet essentiel parce que l'enjeu de
transmission aux nouvelles générations
nécessite qu'on offre de la lisibilité
aux jeunes ce que bosser 7 jours sur 7
70 heures par semaine pour perdre des
ronds aucun jeunes ne peut se porter
là-dessus il y a donc urgent je veux
aussi insister sur le fait que l'été
nous a montré les conséquences graves
concrètes de l'accélération du
changement climatique l'élevage des
tiers c'est le pâturage le pâturage
c'est le stockage de carbone sans
élevage laitiers les prairies sont
retournés et accélèrent le moteur de
réchauffement climatique on attente
encore un peu plus à la biodiversité et
on intensifie l'érosion des sols et y
compris la perte de qualité de l'eau
c'est tout ça qui est en jeu lorsqu'on
prend pas soin de nos agriculteurs à
dimension humaine en matière de
rémunération je veux insister beaucoup
là-dessus monsieur le ministre la
deuxième sujet c'est que la grippe
aviaire elle arrive en Normandie la
ferme du Beaumont chez moi vient d'être
bousculée avec l'émotion que
vous connaissez par ce phénomène je vous
remettrai tout à l'heure en main propre
un courrier pour m'assurer de
l'accompagnement des services de l'État
en Normandie chez moi sur ce phénomène
et peut-être en vous invitant à
accélérer l'expérimentation de la
vaccination intra-européenne notamment
pour les produits pour les bêtes qui ne
sont pas destinées à l'exportation il y
a un enjeu majeur à mettre sur la table
là-dessus j'ai le ministre je commence
par le dernier point la grippe aviaire
la vérité c'est quand même la science
qui dicte les choses donc accélérer on
est dans un les choses ont été
déterminées au mois de mai juin
l'autorisation de faire de procéder à la
stratégie d'expérimentation
l'expérimentation est en cours on aura
des résultats en décembre janvier je
reviens pas sur tous les débats ce qu'on
peut avoir sur la vaccination en général
on a besoin de qualifier d'un point de
vue scientifique donc on est vraiment
dans un processus au processus
objectivement aussi accéléré que
possible vous disiez elle arrive en
Europe le problème c'est que la grippe
aviaire n'est pas parti d'Europe
non mais je veux dire elle arrive en
Normandie en fait elle n'a pas quitté
elle n'a pas quitté elle n'a pas quitté
le territoire national et donc des
difficultés c'est le phénomène nouveau
dans lequel on fait face et c'est pour
ça que la vaccination est un élément
important deux vous avez parlé la
question des Galim d'abord j'ai quand
même noté avec intérêt est-ce que ça je
pense que c'est un débat d'opinion que
nous pourrions mener ensemble c'est un
débat sur la rémunération vous me disiez
38 centimes pour 78 centimes mais 78
centimes ça ne marche pas non plus
compte tenu de ce que sont aujourd'hui
les coûts de production c'est pas ça le
prix du lait d'équilibre qui permet de
rémunérer l'agriculteur le
transformateur
et le distributeur donc il faut aussi
comprendre dans les esprits que c'est
pas le prix d'équilibre 78 centimes j'ai
été un comment dirais intéressé de la
prise de parole d'un certain nombre de
responsables de la grande distribution
annonçant des prix à 500 faut que je le
retrouve dans la descente des prix
alimentaires ça c'est donc c'est ça
qu'on va vérifier c'est si ça doit être
payé 500 producteurs faut que ça soit
payé 500 producteurs et pas que ce soit
payé autrement et pas oui et donc il
faut que c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
regarde et puis troisième élément sur
l'élevage je vous avais dit un mot sur
l'élevage que c'est le sujet des
laitiers en particulier vous avez raison
il faut qu'on pose clairement sur la
table ça a été dit par Dominique petit
l'élevage est un élément déterminant du
modèle actuel et du modèle futur et donc
si on n'arrive pas à passer ce cap
évidemment on a un problème et il faut
qu'on pose le débat de dire on a besoin
d'élevage en France et qu'il faut
arrêter de faire cette chasse et se
montrer du doigt qu'on fait en
permanence à l'élevage bien merci
beaucoup
nous continuons avec Monsieur Molac du
groupe liotte oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues donc moi je vais insister
aussi sur la grippe aviaire parce que
j'ai un certain nombre d'éleveurs chez
moi qui ont des des volailles qui sont
donc
maintenu dans les bâtiments et donc ce
sont des vols en général des variétés
toniques et donc il y a des problèmes de
cannibalisme des problèmes qui et donc
les il y a des propositions qui ont été
faites pour qu'au moins les volailles
puissent sortir autour d'un paquage
autour de de
du bâtiment et c'est soutenu par
beaucoup d'agriculteurs y compris par
les conventionnelles et donc ça ils font
de regarder parce que ils sont obligés
de les sortir en fait la deuxième chose
c'est que les négos sont difficiles avec
la grande distribution
et en particulier avec le lait alors on
dit que c'est en France que le lait est
payé le moins cher de toute l'Europe ce
qui est quand même un peu curieux et
donc je soutiens également bon ce que
disait Dominique Pottier sur l'élevage
laitier et herbaget en particulier c'est
quand même le moyen le plus écologique
que l'on est de pouvoir avoir
d'utilisation de certaines régions qui
avec les conditions pédoclimatiques font
de l'herbe tout simplement donc et je
pense en particulier à la Bretagne alors
pour terminer sur la question de la
sécheresse le département du Morbihan
est le premier département des de
légumes plein champ en France or si on
veut avoir des légumes plein champ avec
les difficultés qu'on peut avoir il nous
faut effectivement pouvoir les arroser
et je tombe sur une autre question c'est
à dire que dans la plupart des cas c'est
il n'arriveront pas en fait à fournir
les kilos nécessaires enfin les ce qu'il
y a dans les contrats pour les
supermarchés parce que tout simplement
ils ont pas eu le la quantité nécessaire
donc là faudrait pas qu'en plus il
faisait des pénalités là-dessus et puis
je vous invite à venir dans ma
circonscription à Brocéliande et vous
verrez qu'il y a un partenariat qui est
très déjà depuis une bonne plus d'une
dizaine d'années entre les agriculteurs
et les pompiers à chaque fois qu'il y a
un incendie chacun chez c'est ce qu'il
faut faire et c'est un appui pour les
pompiers très très important parce que
les agriculteurs amènent toute l'eau les
pompiers ont juste à venir ils font 1 km
ou deux ils remplissent le camion il
retourne au feu et donc ça c'est enfin
en tout cas on a un certain nombre de
choses en une certaine expérience là
dessus puisqu'on a beaucoup de terres de
landes et le problème des terres de
landes c'est que ça brûle
sur les affaires de volaille on a saisi
l'un de ces justement de ces différents
domaines ça fait quoi ce que disait
votre collègue sur sur les autres
filières c'est de regarder dans quelle
mesure on peut assouplir les règles
qu'on a posé de base pour regarder
comment on peut à la fois il faut qu'on
tienne quand même serrer les choses sur
la question d'influence de la Vierge
Sébastien le Jumel disait à juste titre
que elle revient massivement
manifestement et donc la stratégie moi
j'ai fait confiance et j'essaie de faire
confiance aux autorités qui sont faites
pour ça je pense que c'est mieux
d'ailleurs et donc on met ça n'exclut
pas que nous travaillons et ça rejoint
ce que j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure pour
adapter les mesures selon le type
d'élevage parfois des élevages plein air
parfois là des élevages d'une autre
nature qui ont besoin éventuellement
d'avoir ces éléments là sur la question
du lait vous avez tout à fait raison il
y a quand même une interrogation qui est
posée aux filières et elle agrand
distribution en particulier pourquoi le
même LED que selon qu'il est à Bruxelles
ou de l'autre côté de la frontière il
est payé tout à fait différemment
producteur avec des phénomènes en plus
qui sont complètement fous c'est à dire
qu'on a aujourd'hui du lait qui est
vendu à l'extérieur de nos frontières ou
même centrale d'achat
parce qu'il est mieux rémunéré donc on a
un sujet je le dis strictement français
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut qu'on pèse
parce que c'est vraiment une exception
française et c'est une exception du
modèle économique et de modèle de
distribution et il y a aussi des grandes
distributeurs en Allemagne en Belgique
et ailleurs je parle c'est pas ça qui
est le facteur enfin sur le ça fait que
corroborer ce que je dis c'est à dire
que vous avez raison sur la question
dans les pénalités on va éveiller sur la
question de l'excès à l'eau y compris
sur le maraîchage j'ai des secteurs où
ils ont perdu 80% de la récolte parce
qu'il y avait pas d'eau et donc c'est un
élément central que la question de
l'accès à l'eau pour toutes les cultures
et par exemple pour le maraîchage
bien merci beaucoup nous avons terminé
avec les orateurs de groupe on va passer
aux questions individuelles de tous les
députés vous connaissez le principe on
prend toutes les questions une minute
stop chrono maximum et on coupe je vais
commencer donc très longue liste
d'orateur donc vraiment je tiendrai la
minute et on va commencer tout de suite
par Frédéric descrosaï du groupe
Renaissance
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais concentrer ma question
sur un point particulier
je me permets quand même de relever au
passage que la question de l'application
est droit de la concurrence au secteur
agricole
devient de plus en plus Brigante elle a
été relevée par plusieurs orateurs de
groupe et je pense que les conditions
sont mûres pour que on puisse avancer
sur sur ce point là ma question porte
sur une idée qui est en train d'être
je dirais qui est au stade de
laboratoire
de contractualisation entre production
végétale et animale sur les aliments
pour bétail
c'est une idée qui est travaillée par
les responsables professionnels
agricoles en ce moment je pense
personnellement qu'elle mérite d'être
soutenu parce qu'elle est en elle-même
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
l'apaisement entre des filières et en
plus de ça
en sortir de cet été qui permet de
trouver quelque chose d'à peu près
stable dans des contextes de tension sur
les disponibilités fourragères et sur
les prix est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
soutenir une défiscalisation d'une
partie de la production fourragère pour
à destination d'aliments pour bétail
merci beaucoup Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Vigier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la première mission de nos
agriculteurs c'est de produire pour
nourrir la planète et le font très bien
et dans les pour qu'on retrouve notre
souveraineté alimentaire ce sont les
jeudis et force ce sont les premiers
écologistes de France car les
entretiennent les espaces et ouvrent les
paysages cependant aujourd'hui il
souffre il souffre fortement 1 la
sécheresse de cet été a réduit de
manière très forte les quantités de foin
et de fourrage à tel point que certains
agriculteurs ont commencé les réserves
de cet hiver et d'autres ont des
capitalisé en partie 2 les matières
premières sont hors de prix et même si
la hausse des produits qu'ils vendent
n'a pas compensé 3 la loi également 2
n'est pas toujours respectée et 4 les
prédateurs notamment le loup sont de
plus en plus présents et attaquent
fréquemment les troupeaux où est le
bien-être animal aussi Monsieur le
Ministre quelle mesure pouvez-vous
prendre très rapidement j'ai bien très
rapidement pour aider nos agriculteurs
face à ces problèmes sinon il y aura de
la casse merci Madame Laporte
nationale merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre dans son récent
rapport sur la conjoncture laitière le
Centre National Interprofessionnel de
l'économie laitière nous donne un état
des lieux un pronostic alarmant sur
l'évolution du prix du lait et des
produits laitiers industriels en juin
2022 le prix du lait conventionnel avait
augmenté de 25% sur un an 45% pour la
poudre de lait écrémé et 85% pour le
beurre depuis le début de l'année 2022
la collecte de lait de façon presque
constante inférieure à celle de 2021 et
l'indice des prix d'achat des moyens de
production agricoles du labondit de 20%
les industriels du lait craignent
actuellement particulièrement la menace
de délestage qui pèse sur eux alors que
la réfrigération la pasteurisation du
lait exige une consommation énergétique
importante et continue et que 94%
décident de production sont à ce jour
dépourvus de sources d'énergie
alternatives aussi la Fédération
nationale des industriels du lait
viennent de tirer la sonnette d'alarme
et demander que le secteur soit exonéré
de ses délaissage monsieur le ministre
dans un objectif d'atténuer explosion
actuelle du prix du lait de préserver la
production quel va être votre position
merci Madame trouver LFI
bonjour monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président j'aurai une question sur les
produits phytosanitaires puisque le
Grenelle de l'environnement 2008 assuré
une baisse si possible des produits
phytos plus connus sous le nom de
pesticides de 50 % objectif réitérer par
le plan Écophyto pour 2025 puisque on
n'a pas tenu le Grenelle de
l'environnement or en à peu près 10 ans
on a une augmentation de 15% des nombres
de doses d'unité qui est l'indicateur de
référence et pire l'année 2020 c'est
plus 23% et même bien plus pour les
produits les plus dangereux par exemple
au glyphosate 42%. donc c'est un échec
total qui est logique vu la politique
menée depuis 5 ans et l'absence quasi
totale de mesures efficaces pire par
exemple la suppression des aides au
maintien en bio alors cette question que
comptez-vous faire en tant que mesures
efficace par exemple le transfert massif
vers des aides vers le second pilier une
hausse de la condition de la
conditionnalité de la pacte ou la
suppression des pesticides les plus
dangereux ce qui prouverait par ailleurs
ventraindépendance alors que votre ex
chef de cabinet parti vers le lobby des
pesticides merci
Monsieur Bourgeot LR
oui c'est le président monsieur le
ministre ça a été évoqué tout de suite
et je voudrais moi aborder le prix des
fertilisants et l'exemple des matières
azotées avec des prix à plus de 1000 €
la tonne si cela peut passer avec des
céréales autour de 300 euros la tonne
cela n'est pas le cas pour d'autres
productions comme chez moi dans un
bassin légumier important
ces prix deviennent intenables et
provoquent aujourd'hui un changement
d'orientation culturelle qui peut
détruire demain des productions monsieur
le ministre comment voyez-vous l'avenir
et que comptez-vous faire par rapport à
ces fertilisants et leurs coûts merci
Madame bateau écologiste
merci
monsieur le ministre je dois être très
concise quelle sera la position de la
France sur le renouvellement de
l'autorisation du glyphosate allez vous
renouveler les dérogations à
l'interdiction du poison des
néonicotinoïdes sur l'eau vous parliez à
l'instant de dialogue et de gouvernance
partagée en réponse à Dominique Pottier
ce n'est pas la politique de l'État dans
les Deux Sèvres ou un protocole avait
été trouvé et comme vous le savez il
n'est pas respecté ce qui a conduit
nombre d'acteurs à le quitter il y a des
fortes tensions il y a des violences que
je condamne d'où qu'elles viennent
êtes-vous prêts à suspendre les travaux
pour rétablir les chemins du dialogue
merci beaucoup madame Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le ministion très très rapide
concernant le lait nous avons eu l'an
dernier un rapport de nos collègues
Vigier Boyer qui proposait dans leur
proposition numéro 5 l'exonération de la
cicpe sur la collecte de les deux
montagnes je crois que les jeunes
agriculteurs vous ont évoqué cela avec
vous également est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable la deuxième question c'est
concernant les remises de fin de
campagne donc les RFA que les
plateformes grandes surfaces reversent
au magasin on a quand même une opacité
assez grande et ce qui a un suivi précis
notamment sur les marges arrières qui
sont pour certaines
destructrices de valeurs la dernière
question c'est concernant la gouvernance
sur l'eau dont on parlait à l'instant
est-ce que vous êtes favorable au
renforcement du rôle des clés qui
portent les sages localement et qui donc
sont plus au fait des ressources bassins
par bassin
merci Monsieur Lamirault horizon
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
parler de deux sujets le premier c'est
le rôle croissant que vont jouer les
agriculteurs pour les énergies
renouvelables et entre autres le
photovoltaïque peuvent photovoltaïques
pardon et vous dire que le fait que les
assureurs ne refusent d'assurer les
bâtiments à partir du moment où il y a
du photovoltaïque de sous dessus pose un
gros problème au développement de cette
énergie le deuxième c'est la régulation
du Grand Cormoran qui quand on est à 200
km de la mer ne me semble pas une espèce
endémique et donc pourquoi il faut
réguler le nombre de grands cormorans à
tuer sur les pisciculture de
l'Eure-et-Loir ça me semble être un
problème
qu'il faut arriver à résoudre
merci beaucoup monsieur Gérardin
Renaissance
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos liminaire les Pineux problème de
renouvellement générationnel à la tête
des exploitations et particulièrement à
court terme puisque 50% des chefs
d'exploitation vont partir en retraite
d'ici 10 ans et c'est un enjeu Hamon
dans la recherche de l'indépendance
stratégique agricole actuellement un
tiers des exploitations ne sont pas
transmises une part non négligeable se
fait à des tiers donc non en filiation
directe est souvent à des âges avancés
au-delà des outils d'exploitation le cas
du foncier discriminant de la
faisabilité de la transmission en effet
globalement et pour l'ensemble du monde
agricole il y a une décorrélation très
forte entre le prix du foncier et la
rentabilité des exploitations à mon sens
trois axes sont à retenir 1
l'anticipation dans l'approche de la
transmission des exploitations de
l'harmonisation des dispositifs
existants notamment juridiques et
fiscaux et leur élargissement portant
cela le portage foncier 3 est justement
des dispositifs fiscaux notamment
portant sur le bail à long terme le
pacte du trail le report des plus-values
et les filles partager vous ces
orientations je vous remercie beaucoup
madame ménage
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question va être simple
pensez-vous être en mesure de remplir
votre fonction de défenseur de la
souveraineté alimentaire en effet la
question se pose depuis la réunion des
représentants de la filière en divers
ces derniers voient aujourd'hui les prix
d'énergie s'envoler multiplié par 8 ce
qui est tout simplement insupportable
pour nos producteurs d'endives il y a
moins d'un mois vous expliquer sur
France Inter que vous souhaitiez que les
agriculteurs soient mieux rémunérés
rémunérés pardon or vous laissez peser
sur eux une charge énorme une grande
partie de ces exploitants
approvisionnent les cantines de nos
écoles les politiques énergétiques de
votre gouvernement additionné à une
déconsidération des travailleurs de la
terre sont sur le point de provoquer la
mort d'une économie qui contribue de
manière significative à l'autonomie
alimentaire française monsieur le
ministre vous êtes le représentant d'un
gouvernement qui a la responsabilité
d'aggraver la détresse de nombreuses
agriculteurs dont nous ne comptons plus
les suicides depuis 2017 allez-vous
également fragiliser les 350 entreprises
et les 4000 salariés que compte la
filière en divers merci
bien monsieur gaillard elle est si
monsieur le ministre comme vous le savez
la commission de préservation des
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
là sont des outils de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des terres agricoles
permettant de maintenir au développer
l'agriculture périurbaine c'est donc un
outil pertinent à nos yeux à l'échelle
nationale cependant des dispositions
spécifiques sont prévues pour les
territoires ultramarins ainsi l'article
L 182 du code rural et de la pêche
maritime impose notamment pour la
délivrance de permis de construire en
zone agricole de recueillir
préalablement la vie favorable de la CD
P9 cette obligation qui ne s'applique
que dans les outre-mer pose de réelles
difficultés localement de nombreux
contentieux sont en effet initié du fait
d'une interprétation extensive de cet
article par les services de l'État à la
réunion chez nous la CD9 bloque tout
aussi Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
vous engager à appliquer les mêmes
règles en métropole qu'en outre-mer en
cantonnant la cdp9 à un avis simple je
vous remercie
monsieur bolo modem merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre alors que
l'approche du jour meilleur fleurissait
dans les campagnes alors que la sortie
de crise permettait d'entrevoir la
reprise de l'activité l'inquiétude
revient avec la nouvelle la mauvaise
nouvelle du retour de l'influence à
vierge qui fait redouter le pire il faut
saluer l'action du gouvernement qui a
répondu aux conséquences sanitaires et
économiques avec un effort financier de
plus d'un milliard d'euros la question
que je souhaite vous poser la suivante
est-ce que la gestion de la Nouvelle
Vague va s'accompagner d'une continuité
dans l'accompagnement des éleveurs
impactés et vous l'avez souligné il en
va aussi de la pérennité d'une filière
qui pèse 7,7 milliards d'euros et de
l'accès à notre alimentation et comme
vous l'avez dit cet Axel alimentation
c'est la continuité de la chaîne donc en
termes de continuité il y aura-t-il une
continuité en prolongeant l'action du
gouvernement vers la nouvelle crise
merci Madame Marceau Renaissance
de nombreuses filières sont concernés
par leur aspect de cahiers des charges
des appellations d'origine contrôlée
lianao qui en est le rédacteur mais un
soin scrupuleux à en contrôler le
respect c'est une fierté c'est une
garantie et on ne remet pas je n'en
remet pas ça en cause le bassin de
production du cognac est un des fleurons
de nos appellations d'origine contrôlée
confronté à la nécessité de mettre en
oeuvre un plan de sobriété et plus
généralement engagée dans une mutation
profonde rendue impérative par le
changement climatique la filière Cognac
se heurte à la lenteur de la réécriture
de certains de ces éléments de cahier
des charges en particulier relatif à
l'utilisation du gaz naturel pour
l'étape de la distillation et donc à son
remplacement par de nouvelles énergies
en cours d'expérimentation que sont la
récupération de chaleur la vapeur et je
sais que vous connaissez vous êtes venus
voir tout cela pensez-vous monsieur le
ministre qui serait possible d'accélérer
les process de rédaction au sein de
lianao pour nous permettre davantage
d'agilité à nos filières d'excellence
merci Madame en grand
merci monsieur le Président et monsieur
le ministre par l'intermédiaire d'un
courrier daté du 19 août 2022 j'avais
voulu attirer votre attention sur la
situation critique à laquelle la
sécheresse exposait les éleveurs je vous
avertissez déjà que les éleveurs
n'allaient pas pouvoir se fournir en
fourrage à des prix normaux cet hiver et
que certains d'entre eux envisagaient
déjà au mois d'août de vendre une partie
de leur bête je vous propose alors de
prolonger l'aide du plan résilience
visant à pallier les surcoûts de
l'alimentation animale imputable à la
crise en Ukraine alors que cette aide
avait pris fin le 17 juillet dernier
vous imaginez ma surprise lorsque j'ai
pris connaissance de votre récente
intervention dans le Figaro vous vous
résignez à admettre que la situation de
cet été était pire que celle du
printemps concernant le fourrage et que
vous craignez la décapitalisation à
défaut d'avoir répondu à mes
sollicitations vous partagez un mois
plus tard mon constat ma question est
donc la suivante monsieur le ministre
alors que la guerre en Ukraine n'est pas
achevée prévoyez-vous de remettre très
rapidement en place une aide destinée à
pallier les surcoûts de production pour
les agriculteurs et éviter cette
décapitalisation qui m’est gravement en
danger leurs exploitations
monsieur le ministre quelques questions
très rapide et très ciblées comment
comptez-vous et comptez-vous agir pour
favoriser le stockage de l'eau par les
agriculteurs quand on sait qu'à né après
année bien ça va être de plus en plus
difficile pour eux de faire face au
manque de ressources hydriques sur les
prix de l'énergie qui vont rester
durablement comment comptez-vous
favoriser les projets de production
d'énergie sur les exploitations
agricoles quand on a vu le travail fait
sur la remise en cause et contrats
photovoltaïques les complexités
administratives sur les dossiers
incertains de choses je pense que ça
devient urgent quels sont vos projets
vous avez parlé du renouvellement des
générations pour revaloriser la filière
de formation des lycées agricoles pour
les préparer au métier d'agriculteurs de
demain et enfin je rebondis sur ce qu'a
dit le collègue par rapport au grand
corps Morand ils sont 100 000
aujourd'hui ils étaient 1000 dans les
années 70 ils n'ont pas de prédateurs
consomment chacun un demi kilo de
poisson par jour êtes-vous favorable à
la régulation de cette espèce qui pose
de plus en plus de problèmes y compris
pour la reconstitution des milieux
aquatiques qu'on essaie d'opérer dans
territoires merci beaucoup madame Morel
modem merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre député du baron je
suis interpellé sur le sujet de la
difficulté d'approvisionnement en
caneton par des exploitants agricoles en
Alsace ces derniers il s'approvisionnent
pour la plupart en Vendée qui face à la
hausse de cas de Guy ripavière a du
procédé à l'abattage de nombreux
canetons conformément au protocole en
vigueur cela contribue à une hausse
importante du coût de cette matière
première pour les transformateurs de
canetons en divers produits mais au-delà
du coup cela pose la question de la
quantité d'offres globalement disponible
pour assurer leur propre production en
conséquence pour ne citer qu'un exemple
la ferme Schmitt à Bischoffsheim perd
25% de son chiffre d'affaires annuel
multipliant ainsi d'autres difficultés
remboursement des investissements liés à
la modernisation de leur outil de
production maintient des postes etc Cela
est identique pour d'autres exploitants
et dans d'autres territoires dans la
Sarthe mon collègue le député Martino
également donc pour clarifier les choses
en tant que zone indême les exploitants
ne peuvent bénéficier d'indemnités ma
question motivante quelle mesure
pouvons-nous prendre et comment assurer
que nos éleveurs puissent offrir en
quantité suffisante du foie gras à Noël
se produit emblématique de nos tables de
fêtes
merci beaucoup
madame Goulet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question porte sur la
situation des producteurs de lait cela
fait longtemps que la filière les tiers
est en crise et que de nombreux
producteurs de lait ne sont pas
rémunérés à leur juste valeur en vingt
ans la France a perdu plus de la moitié
de ses producteurs ce risque de pénurie
cette diminution du nombre de
producteurs nous privent d'un
savoir-faire d'éleveur expérimenté et de
ceux qui garantissent la sécurité
alimentaire des consommateurs français
à cette situation de crise s'ajoute
l'impact de la crise énergétique les
éleveurs sont inquiets pour les
prochaines pour le de futurs coupures
hivernales avec de graves conséquences
sur le fonctionnement quotidien de leurs
exploitations et sur leurs élevages en
termes de bien-être animal quelle
garantie leur apportez-vous dans ce
contexte de crise énergétique
merci
monsieur
le ministre ma question porte sur les
retenu colinéaires on sait que c'est un
des moyens pour concilier à la fois des
le développement durable et le maintien
d'irrigation pour nous agriculteurs
notamment pendant les périodes de
sécheresse il y a une réelle volonté
pour aller sur
ces infrastructures que ça soit
politique je vois notamment au niveau du
conseil départemental où ce siège dans
l'un à travers l'aide de la politique de
l'eau où elle est aux agriculteurs et à
la fois tous les syndicats ou agricoles
quels qu'ils soient souhaiteraient aller
dessus aujourd'hui un problème de
lourdeur administrative avec les règles
d'urbanisme en particulier les PPRN
parfois qui rendent difficile les
retenues colinaires je parle en
particulier or évidemment
barrage maçonnés les péperennes l'état
la main dessus que pourrait-on faire
pour accélérer
les retenus la procédure et impulser une
réelle dynamique où il y a une volonté
commune d'aller sur ces sur ces outils
merci Monsieur de fonda RN
merci monsieur le Président c'est
Monsieur de formation
pas de souci monsieur le ministre je
vous ai entendu évoqué la question les
incendies de forêt avec intérêt étant
élu de Gironde ayant vécu durant tous
les thés sur ma circonscription de
multiples incendies de feu provoqués
pour la plupart par des pyromanes vous
l'avez évoqué la France entière s'est
rendu compte que la Gironde avait des
forêts et qu'elles étaient sensibles aux
incendies ce qui est en réalité ce qui
est en réalité n'est pas nouveau vous le
savez la base des bombardiers d'eau est
à Nîmes et la Gironde ne dispose pas
comme la Corse du prépositionnement de
Canadair c'est un véritable problème
quand on sait qu'il faut au moins deux
heures pour qu'ils arrivent sur la
Gironde depuis Nîmes et que la première
heure d'un incendie déterminante pour
éviter qu'il ne dégénère nous avons
besoin de votre intervention pour que la
Gironde soit dotée d'un
prépositionnement de Canadair pendant la
saison des feux de forêts que
comptez-vous faire pour l'obtenir
merci Monsieur dive
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre 1800 euros par hectare c'est la
somme que vercing belge pour pouvoir
sous louer des terres dans les hauts de
France c'est un agriculteur pour pouvoir
cultiver des pommes de terre tout
simplement dans une région où ils sont
même d'ailleurs subventionnés moi je
veux subventionner par l'État belge bien
sûr je veux juste vous alerter sur cette
situation j'avais déjà alerté vos
prédécesseurs depuis Stéphane Le Foll
sur une situation comme celle-ci qui me
fait que se développer où on a
effectivement des producteurs belges qui
sous le don des terres avec des plans
propres à eux avec des matériels parfois
non conformes et cela sans contrôle de
la part de l'État sans contrôle non
seulement c'est immoral c'est en
psychologique et surtout illégal est-ce
que vous pourrez bien sûr vous attaquer
à cette question
merci Madame dumuller
merci monsieur le ministre je souhaitais
m'exprimer sur deux dossiers qui
préoccupent particulièrement les
agriculteurs de Haute-Savoie le loup et
la bruxellose vous le savez les attaques
du loup sur nos territoires alpin sont
de plus en plus fréquentes et violentes
ils attaquent en meute sont habitués à
la présence de l'homme puisqu'il
n'hésite plus à s'approcher des
habitations bon nombre d'agriculteurs
ont d'ores et déjà commencé à retirer
leurs bêtes des alpages pour les
redescendre en exploitation or si les
troupeaux désertent les alpages ce sera
la fin de production de beaucoup de
produits locaux soumis à des
IGP ou des AOP qui dépendent du degré
d'altitude de pâturages sans compter la
fin de l'entretien des alpages qui sont
nécessaires aux activités à la fois
agricoles mais aussi touristiques donc
nous attendons de votre part une
position tranchée sur ce sujet et puis
sur la question de la bruxellose nous
attendons toujours les résultats du
laboratoire vétérinaire de
Maisons-Alfort sur les vaches qu'ils ont
été abattues suite un cas chez un
éleveur dans le massif du Bargy donc là
aussi c'est un dossier sur lequel nous
attendons de vous une position ferme
merci
donc il y a un décalage de phase on
pourrait dire entre ces aides et leur
futur situation
merci beaucoup monsieur Villiers
oui monsieur le ministre
la question est très courte un mot de
votre part sur les retraites agricoles
et en particulier sur les retraites des
épouses d'agriculteurs
[Musique]
et au vu de cette liste on décidera
collectivement avec le bureau toutes les
missions que nous lançons dès le début
du mois d'octobre ça correspond à ce
qu'on s'est dit en réunion de bureau
après cette très longue série de section
de questions pardon monsieur le ministre
je vais vous laisser la parole il est
16h47 j'allais dire si en un quart
d'heure on peut ramasser les réponses
histoire de terminer à 17h ce serait
bien on aurait que 30 minutes de retard
si vous souhaitez un petit peu plus on
peut déborder monsieur le ministre mais
c'est à vous les 30 minutes de mon
intervention
[Rires]
je pense que je peux te dire mais vous
me pardonnerez mais évidemment ça
nécessitera des itérations
complémentaires avec vous et on est à
votre disposition pour répondre sur des
Crozet m'a interrogé sur un système au
fond qui est un système complémentaire
assurantiel et de solidarité qui
permettront parler voix de la fiscalité
de la défiscalisation de la
fiscalisation prenez le par le de les
aller bonnes années de pouvoir ne pas
payer trop d'impôts pour après les
mauvaises années dans une autre
configuration donc et que ça alimente un
mécanisme de solidarité avec les élans
moi je trouve que le système qui est
proposé alors je n'ai pas le détail pour
être très clair le parait intéressant
dans son fondement et son principe parce
que c'est un mécanisme à la fois de
solidarité et qui vise la réponse aux
aléas
ici en élevage là en grande culture
après il faut voir le dispositif la
fiscalisation que ça demande et s'il y a
pas des effets d'Eaubonne et de bordure
qui peuvent être créés donc c'est ça
qu'il faut regarder mais il y a des
systèmes je pense à en viticulture qui
sont des systèmes comme ça sur le
stockage qui permet de parfois de faire
face à sa profession se saisissent de
cette question et nous fasse des
propositions je trouve que c'est plutôt
un bon signe et donc il faut les
encourager en regardant les choses
pour tous vous avez dans le budget 2023
ça me paraît un peu compliqué mais en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut le poser
parce que ce dérèglement climatique pose
des dérèglements de production qui
doivent être à appuyé sur les systèmes
assurantiel de nature diverses monsieur
Vigier a rappelé à juste titre ce que
j'avais dit et donc je rejoins tout à
fait ce qu'il dit pour
pour la nécessité de soutenir en
particulier les éleveurs et la vocation
de produire pour nourrir qui me paraît
essentiel à rappeler de temps en temps
parce que parfois elle est un peu
éloignée il a évoqué tous les sujets que
je verrai évoquer qu'on a déjà évoqué
c'est la question de l'accès aux
matières premières c'est le sens du
point de résilience la question de la
sécheresse c'est le sens des mesures que
je vous ai
représenté si je peux dire qui
permettront de répondre aux besoins de
trésorerie et s'il y a besoin d'autres
dispositifs nous le ferons évidemment
c'est dans un cadre plus global et je
répondrai globalement sur la question de
la prédation si vous me le permettez
madame trouvé au-delà parfois des
caractères un peu caricatural et y
compris des mises en cause personnelle
d'abord je vais vous dire trois choses
d'abord il y a des il y a des faits sur
les cmr1 on a réduit de 90%
l'utilisation des céréma ça c'est un
fait de pour la première fois on a
réduit l'utilisation du glyphosate 3 6
et simple je vous le dis ça serait parce
que moi je ne mettrai pas l'agriculture
française parce que Madame nous ne
sommes pas une île déserte
et donc nous avons autour de nous des
gens qui produisent si c'est pour se
retrouver dans la situation où on
flingue des filières parce qu'on leur
interdit un produit quand tout autour de
nous en Europe
on ne pose pas le débat donc je suis
d'accord avec vous pour poser le débat
et aller même plus que poser le débat
avancez sur ces sujets mais il faut le
faire au niveau européen parce que
résultat la politique que vous proposez
c'est une politique d'affaiblissement
des productions agricoles françaises
parce que il y a une mécanique simple
quand vous interdisez un produit sur la
cerise et que les mêmes cerises peuvent
venir sur notre marché dans le monde
dans le cas oui mais on est on est donc
c'est au niveau européen donc donc nous
sommes en Europe madame je sais que vous
n'êtes pas partisan de l'Europe mais il
me semble que nous avons besoin de
d'être sur deux logiques à quelque chose
qui ne vient pas introduire des
distorsions de concurrence
supplémentaires entre nous une européen
de les interdictions sur sans solution
ça n'est pas un modèle pour moi et donc
il faut aussi chercher des alternatives
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire sur un
certain nombre de produits
et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut et c'est
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
très facile derrière une table de dire
c'est faisable Yaka faucon c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça permettez-moi de
vous le dire
je vais finir pour tenir dans les 15
minutes monsieur le Président si vous me
permettez sur la question des
fertilisants et des coups de
fertilisants on a effectivement une
hausse défertilisant on a deux sujets
c'est d'abord de faire en sorte que les
endroits où ça produit et nous sommes en
situation de dépendance faut le se le
dire depuis très longtemps sur la
question de la production donc un que
j'ai quand même un accès dans le moment
que nous traversons parce que il y a des
grandes interrogations sur la saison 2
on a besoin de fertilisant mais on a
besoin aussi d'avoir une transition de
fertilisant minéraux vers les fertiliser
organique et donc c'est aussi ça ce
qu'il faut faire comme mouvement ça
rejoint ce que disait monsieur potier
sur l'intérêt de l'élevage et l'utiliser
l'utilité d'élevage dans le modèle mais
il y a les urgences du moment mais ça ne
doit pas nous écarter de 1 retrouver
notre souveraineté et deux de regarder
la mobilisation plus grande qui pourrait
être faite pour mieux mobiliser les
fertilisants organiques il me semble que
ça c'était un élément important dans la
logique que nous devons mettre à
l'oeuvre il y a un effet pour l'instant
sur les grandes cultures ça couvre
plutôt mais il peut y avoir un effet
ciseaux qui viennent et s'efface que les
prix des grandes des céréales B100 là on
soit dans une difficulté grande parce
que le prix des fertilisants donc on dit
il faut qu'on sorte de la dépendance et
avoir des mesures d'urgence pour essayer
de fluidifier le marché autant que faire
ce peu madame bateau vous m'avez
interrogé sur néonicotinoïdes par
mettez-moi de dire qu'il y a une loi qui
a été votée il y a des éminents experts
sur le sujet dans cette salle il y a un
travail qui a été fait de recherche qui
est en cours
en cours de deuxième année la ligne qui
a été défendue à l'époque par contre les
ccesseurs c'était pas l'interdiction
sans solution et on cherche des
solutions je rappelle que 20 millions
d'euros ont été mis sur la recherche
donc je peux pas prémpeter un débat mais
le débat pour moi c'est bien de la
sortie c'était bien ça le sujet mais
sauf qu'on a besoin d'éclairer ça par
les solutions alternatives qu'on doit
offrir aussi aux producteurs de
betteraves quant à la question du
glyphosate pour moi c'est un sujet je
l'ai dit à l'instant sur d'autres sujets
c'est un sujet naturel je rajoute que
pour la première fois
oui c'est c'est moi le faire le
préambule je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question
d'abord de dire que depuis là pour la
première fois on a une diminution
d'utilisation du glyphosate un tiers des
exploitations n'utilise plus glyphosate
30% des exploitations sont en cours de
sortie du glyphosate donc on est quand
même sur un chemin par ailleurs on va
regarder au niveau européen pour avoir
une position harmonisée il y a une chose
que je ne ferai pas c'est d'avoir une
position isolée donc on est en train de
travailler moi j'ai besoin aussi au
niveau européen qu'on éclaire ma
lanterne sur les solutions alternatives
au glyphosate la ligne elle a été
déterminée par le Président de la
République on a avancé puisque il y a un
certain nombre d'exploitations qui sont
sur la voie de la sortie ou qui sont
déjà sortis mais j'ai besoin qu'on
puisse éclairer aussi par des faits ce
que peuvent être les alternatives y
compris au niveau européen il me semble
que c'est un apport un élément important
madame Baptiste
j'évoque simplement la question de la
gouvernance de l'eau peut-être qui était
un élément important que vous m'avez
posé trois questions mais j'en ai une
qui m'échappe du coup là ou deux mains
du coup sur la gouvernance de l'eau
oui je vais regarder sur la tcpe si on
va regarder ce que je peux mettre les
éléments et comment ça peut est-ce que
ça a une ça peut avoir un effet est-ce
que ça tient dans nos cadres
réglementaires sur la question la
gouvernance de l'eau
est-ce que c'est les sages est-ce que
c'est les pros territoriaux territoriaux
de gestion de l'eau est-ce que c'est les
échelles départementales j'ai pas encore
d'avis tout à fait déterminé sur la
bonne échelle de gouvernance mais non
parce que les sages si vous voulez moi
je je suis dans une région où le sage il
est immense or on a des sujets un moment
de housse fait l'ouvrage comment ça
fonctionne il me semble pas que ce soit
assez micro comme échelle par ailleurs
je constate aussi que dans les sages il
y a beaucoup de querelles qui se
nourrissent
mais je constate ça aussi il faut c'est
pas c'est pas un drame le sage doit être
aussi le lieu du débat du dialogue et du
consensus or je me remonte des
difficultés de cette nature là sur la
gestion donc on a besoin de regarder
quel est le bon lieu de décision et il
me semble
que il y a besoin aussi de poser la
question de la gouvernance à la bonne
échelle territoriale
il me semble que c'est plutôt une
échelle moi mon sens mais on pourra en
parler une échelle infra départementale
c'est plutôt comme ça que je ferai me
semble-t-il les choses monsieur
Lamirault m'a interrogé sur la question
de du photovoltaïque enfin de la grille
voltaïque
et les cormorans
globalement sur l'énergie ça me
permettra de répondre je ne sais plus
qui c'est Monsieur difficile et pour
peut-être qu'il m'a posé une question
sur la question aussi cormoran comme
quoi d'un département à l'autre même
lointain il peut y avoir des sujets
communs
moi je pense qu'il faut que
l'agriculture ça a été dit par Monsieur
Philippot je crois prennent toute sa
place dans la capacité à produire de
l'énergie c'est le photovoltaïque c'est
la méthanisation c'est la biomasse donc
on a pas parlé c'est pour c'est pourquoi
dans les débats que vous aurez sur les
sur le texte qui va être soumis à votre
approbation la question à révoltaïsme
est clairement mais clairement posée il
faut qu'on arrive à gérer une double
contrainte si je peux dire c'est que la
grivevoltaïne c'est bien Agri voltaïsme
il faut pas il faut qu'on analyse le
risque pourrait y avoir d'accaparement
de terre par des opérateurs
en termes foncier et qui se part de la
vertu agricole pour éviter mais c'est
pas pour autant qu'il faut exclure cette
partie photovoltaïque il y a la question
des bâtiments déjà existants qui peut
être un élément mais ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher que la question de le faire au
sol et de il faut quand même être très
vigilant pour le pour ne pas que se
développe ce que je vois en tout cas
dans des projets une concurrence d'usage
réel réel
mais je pense qu'il y a un point
équilibre le troisième élément de
l'équilibre de la grivevoltaïs pour moi
c'est d'avoir de la planification on a
besoin de combien de surface
au niveau départemental Dans les cdp9 et
ça évitera que des gens viennent se
jeter sur des terres de manière diverse
sans qu'on puisse réguler les choses
donc oui il faut du développement des
énergies oui il faut qu'on ait de la
régulation et attention au phénomène de
bordure que je vois arriver assez vite
et compris dans l'installation des
nouvelles générations
qu'on se retrouve pas dans la situation
où ça vienne privée là aussi c'est une
question d'action foncière un certain
nombre de nouveaux qui voudraient
s'installer parce que on aurait installé
des
agriculteurs agricoles qui seraient pas
tout à fait de nature agricole il me
semble qu'on soit il faut qu'on soit
vigilant sur la question
pardonnez-moi ce que c'est pas le même
degré mais je le dis à Madame dubulaire
pour la question de prédation mais Lou
et cormoran qui ne sont pas des objets
de même nature j'en ai un petit peu
conscience quand même
je trouve que
on a du mal à poser tranquillement le
débat dans les termes que je vais
essayer de poser devant vous il y a des
espèces qui ont été protégées parce
qu'elles étaient en voie de disparition
en risque de disparition ou d'extinction
c'est logique c'est normal et ça
participe de la volonté que nous avons
tous devraient en direction de la
biodiversité mais il y a un moment il
faut se poser la question de la
régulation de ces espèces quand elles
viennent perturber
dans des territoires des productions des
cycles ou des équilibres le système il
est anthropisé on le voit on le veut pas
c'est comme ça
donc on peut pas se retrouver dans la
situation que parce que nous aurions
pris des mesures de protection que je
défends quand elles sont utiles et quand
elles sont nécessaires compte tenues des
stations de l'espèce après on estime que
c'est un statut quo général et c'est la
question qui est posée sur la question
du loup et j'aurai l'occasion de
m'exprimer au Conseil européen sur ce
sujet là parce qu'il faut on est dans un
sujet désormais de risque de disparition
de l'élevage y compris sous forme bovine
si vous permettez cette expression parce
que ça ne tiendra pas parce que d'abord
c'est un sentiment d'incompréhension
très violent du monde agricole sur cette
question avec le sentiment qu'on leur
donne des injonctions totalement
contradictoires
et deux quand vous êtes à attaqué 5 6 7
fois c'est pas la question de
l'indemnisation qui compte c'est
simplement que vous n'avez plus envie de
produire et si on n'est pas capable de
comprendre la détresse du monde agricole
qui est en train de se transformer en
colère
on fait des fois notre responsabilité
vis-à-vis d'eux et on fait au défaut
avec de notre responsabilité vis-à-vis
de ce qu'on défend par ailleurs d'un
système agricole qui a des vertus en
termes de biodiversité de stockage
carbone de maintien des prairies
d'ouverture du paysage de lutte contre
l'emprichissement et donc les incendies
et donc à un moment quand le statut de
l'espèce
et satisfaisant il faut se poser la
question des limites qu'on fixe à ça
donc il me semble que c'est valable pour
le cormoran dans des mesures qui sont
d'une autre nature mais c'est la même
sujet je répète je trouve normal qu'on
protège des espèces qui sont menacées et
à un moment quand le statut n'est plus
un statut de menace il faut s'interroger
on est dans un phénomène en plus
d'implantation sur le loup alors vous
vous étiez malheureusement plus plus en
avance de phase dans l'arcalpin mais
l'installation du loup dans le Massif
Central est un sujet
quand même
y compris sur des productions à haute
valeur ajoutée et ce n'est pas une
question d'indemnisation c'est une
question d'équilibre cette affaire et si
on n'est pas capable de dire que c'est
une question d'équilibre y compris de
porter des débats au niveau européen ce
que je vais faire pas plus tard que la
semaine prochaine parce que le sujet que
vous évoquez parfois circonscrit au
niveau français il est en train de
gagner toute l'Europe on ferait défaut
me semble-t-il à notre responsabilité et
c'est pareil il me semble il me semble
pour la question du cormoran
j'ai été interrogé à plusieurs reprises
sur la question
particulier par les députés du
rassemblement national nous infligeons
un peu la responsabilité de la hausse
des coûts de l'énergie je vous invite à
aller regarder bien bien droit vers
l'est et vous aurez déjà une partie de
votre réponse ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
ne fait rien et qu'on ne fait pas des
choses
[Musique]
on a mis un certain nombre de mesures
dans le cadre du plan de résilience ça
me permet de répondre enfin Monsieur
dive la juste suggéré mais ça ne
m'étonne pas c'est un peu son territoire
sur les questions des endives on a un
sujet je recevais pas plus tard que
avant de venir vous rejoindre je
recevais que les responsables des
endiviers parce que là ils ont un sujet
énergétique on a un dispositif qui avait
été mis sur la table dans le cadre du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif projet de loi de finance
rectificatif du mois de juillet
manifestement il faut se le dire les
dispositifs étaient pas bien ajustés par
rapport à la réalité de la production
agricole on est en train d'ajuster les
dispositifs de regarder les histoires de
seuil de regarder les histoires de seuil
de déclenchement de regarder les
montants parce que évidemment quand vous
écoutez les gens des endives qui disent
qu'ils étaient à 80 000 de de dépenses
énergétique et qui sont à 800 000
ça peut pas se régler par la question
des prix
mais reconnaissons quand même en
particulier dans le secteur agricole que
l'État a été très puissamment au
rendez-vous de toutes les crises qu'il y
a eu simplement il faut qu'on qualifie
il faut qu'on quantifie dans un contexte
budgétaire qui n'est pas un contexte
simple on va dire les choses comme elles
sont donc parce que le budget de l'État
c'est pas le budget du gouvernement le
budget de l'État c'est le budget des
Français et donc ce que ce qui n'est pas
dans les prix c'est dans le budget ce
qui est dans le budget c'est de la dette
c'est
aussi qu'on a devant nous donc il faut
qu'on essaie de mesurer mais on sera au
rendez-vous d'un certain nombre de
propositions pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse faire passer ce cap
énergétique qui évidemment un cas
absolument crucial vous avez parlé pour
les uns des endives pour dire la même
chose sur l'élevage sur l'élevage
laitier
sur toutes les unités de transformation
agroalimentaires ça fait un peu de vie
dans le dans la salle d'avoir de la
musique il me semble que là on a besoin
on aura besoin avec vous de qualifier
les besoins qui ne sont pas de même
nature et je pense que c'est important
de se le dire
sur la question de la CDPA
alors c'est toujours paradoxal c'est un
disposition législative qui avait été
posé pour dire des choses très
simplement pour éviter les
la grande spéculations foncière que
certains
imaginez sur les territoires d'outre-mer
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans ce cadre là
c'est un peu une réalité quand même qui
se risque
après c'est assez paradoxal au moment où
on demande de la différenciation c'est
que vous redemandez mais je vous fais
pas grief enfin d'une forme
d'uniformatini d'uniformisation alors
que pour moi les sujets que vous évoquez
sont pas les mêmes chez vous que en
Lozère que dans le Loir-et-Cher ou
qu'ailleurs donc je veux bien qu'on
exploie la question on est en train de
regarder les questions après il me
semble qu'il faut
j'ai tendance à penser qu'il faudrait
aussi essayer de renouer le dialogue
local pour que ça soit pas simplement un
motif de rejet permanent et qui puisse y
avoir des projets qui puissent naître
mais allez modifier la loi faut faire
attention à ce qu'on ouvre pas une porte
parce qu'un avis simple c'est on fait ce
qu'on veut à la fin parfois et donc on a
quand même besoin de réguler ces
questions du foncier
[Musique]
je suis potier se réveille j'ai dit
foncier
non non je blague
non mais on a besoin de se poser ces
questions du foncier et donc simplement
laisser la porte ouverte il n'est pas
mal que au niveau départemental et au
niveau territorial les territoires se
saisissent de la régulation du foncier
mais j'essaie de vous
je n'étais pas législateur à l'époque
mais j'essaie de vous expliquer que ce
que je comprends c'est que ça avait été
fait pour plutôt projet pour protéger
les outre-mer de phénomènes de
spéculation foncière dont on ne peut pas
dire qu'elle n'est pas ce qui naît elle
n'est pas existé c'est c'est
problématiques donc mais faudra qu'on en
met volontiers pour en parler avec vous
j'ai pas de j'ai aucune difficulté pour
en parler avec vous ça mérite des d'être
éclairé plusieurs ont évoqué sur la
question des éleveurs
et la continuité de l'élevage oui on est
un alors
à date on peut pas dire qu'on constate
une décapitalisation elle ne date pas de
cette année elle est un phénomène
continu vous l'avez dit pour plusieurs
d'entre vous il y a un risque cette
année d'un accélération de la
décapitalisation ça a été dit par
plusieurs monsieur potier Monsieur
Benoît et d'autres monsieur bref on a
cette difficulté là devant nous ce qui
fait qu'il faut qu'on réponde à des
mesures d'urgence puis qu'après pour
leur donne des perspectives les mesures
d'urgence c'est la question du prix
parce que ce qui cumule cette année
c'est la question du prix et la question
de la sécheresse les mesures d'urgence
c'est la question du prix je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure je ne désespère pas loin
sans faut que les opérateurs de la
distribution fassent leur travail et
désormais que deux ou trois ont affiché
des prix de rémunération que ça c'est un
effet sur l'ensemble des autres parce
qu'ils sont en concurrence entre eux et
j'invite à porter le débat comme un
débat le prix c'est la souveraineté
la rémunération du producteur c'est la
souveraineté et je suis sûr que ce
combat là on peut le mener
contre ceux qui pensent que le bon prix
célibaterie vraiment je pense que dans
le moment qu'on vit compris nous
concitoyens avec des difficultés ça a
été dit pour certains en terme de
précarité mais pour une immense majorité
d'entre eux
il me semble que cette question de
porter l'axe souveraineté au travers de
la question de la rémunération est une
idée qui peut prospérer y compris dans
la grande distribution parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on imposera dans le débat
qu'il faut que les gens soient payés
pour qu'ils se conçoit avec dans les
états ce qu'il faut sinon la chaîne
alimentaire se rompre
et donc faut le dire il faut le dire
plus encore que je ne le fais là me
semble-t-il ça a été évoqué par
plusieurs la question de la grippe
aviaire alors on a plusieurs sujets
c'est
continuité repeuplement on est on suit
en continu parce qu'il y a des
engagements qui ont été pris par la
filière pour faire en sorte que le
repeuplement se fasse dans des
conditions qui fasse que tout le monde
puisse être un peu entre guillemets
servi parce qu'on a un sujet du fait ça
aussi ça pose des questions à la filière
et c'est sur là-dessus qu'on les engage
la concentration des accouvoirs sur
quelques territoires fait que quand la
grippe aviaire est passée il y avait pas
d'alternative puisque les étaient dans
quelques départements et donc du coup la
capacité à se re fournir c'est donc on
veille à ça première élément
deuxièmement ça a été dit par plusieurs
d'entre vous monsieur bolo monsieur
Martine ou à d'autres c'est on a le
sujet des zones indemnes non indemnisés
donc on est en train de travailler on
est en train de travailler avec les
services on a un sujet réglementaire
tout ça parce qu'il faut essayer
d'expliquer pourquoi on donne des aides
à des gens qui manifestement
ne serait pas en situation d'avoir été
touché par la grippe aviaire donc c'est
un sujet à la fois réglementaire un
sujet de
comment dirais-je de tuyauterie et donc
on voit on voit bien le la difficulté
qu'on a et la difficulté dans laquelle
ça place un certain nombre d'éleveurs
même si c'est pas un grand nombre mais
c'est très sensible et donc ça c'est un
deuxième sujet qui nous paraît important
de travailler j'ai pas encore la
solution je vais pas vous dire le
contraire mais c'est bien identifié
comme problème plusieurs d'entre vous
m'ont sollicité sur cette question là et
c'est important de le dire
dernier point la question dans deux
points pour être rapide et essayer de
tenir vers 17h j'aurais pas trop débordé
monsieur le Président
la question du cahier des charges des
AOC à vous poser un problème spécifique
à votre territoire que j'ai assez bien
identifié le territoire du cognac et
on a un sujet c'est qu'il faut qu'on se
pose posément là aussi le dérèglement
climatique pose la question quand vous
avez des systèmes où on dit dans la dans
la réglementation c'est uniquement
système herbage et sans capacité d'aller
chercher du fourrage à l'extérieur et
que Vous demandez une dérogation tous
les ans va falloir qu'on acte
mais il faut pas que ça dégrade l'image
de nos productions de qualité que quand
même une défense de notre pays que nous
défendons et que je défends au premier
chef c'est AOP aocigé enfin tous les
signes de qualité sont importants donc
il faut à la fois travailler sur des
cahiers des charges parce que une
dérogation qui vient tous les dents ça
n'est pas une dérogation
c'est une règle
donc au lieu de penser seulement
dérogation il faut penser mais c'est un
gros travail que nous avons à faire en
particulier avec les NAO c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin de faire évoluer tout en
tenant la qualité et l'exigence du
cahier des charges et linao a raison
défendre cette exigence là c'est la
force du modèle
mais en même temps de faire en sorte que
nous regardions ce qu'est la réalité
des temps de dérèglement climatique et
il y a des modèles
qui sont plus tout à fait en adéquation
et c'est valable dans le cognac et c'est
valable dans plein d'autres filières il
y a plein de gens à qui ça doit faire
écho enfin j'en finis et ça me permet je
sais plus qu'il a évoqué c'est la
question des formations agricoles
je l'évoquais dans mon propos liminaire
notamment sur la partie d'abord
j'ai pas été dit comme ça mais les
filières de l'enseignement agricole sont
des filières qui attirent c'est la seule
filière cette année dans un contexte
démographique global de diminution des
effectifs parce que la démographie est
ainsi faite l'enseignement agricole
c'est le seul enseignement qui voit sa
population ces jeunes croître
c'est donc il y a bien une attractivité
dans l'enseignement agricole globalement
et ça c'est pas le fruit du hasard c'est
la spécificité de ce modèle qui est très
inclusif qui permet à plus de 80% de
jeunes parfois dans des situations très
délicates au démarrage de trouver une
voie comme citoyen puis de trouver une
voie professionnelle parce que c'est les
deux piliers qui doivent être travaillés
c'est un phénomène c'est un
enseignement qui est très inclusif et
c'est absolument qui parfois basé
beaucoup sur le modèle des internats
tout ça construit quelque chose d'un
écosystème qui trouve plutôt écho
dans la population tous les jeunes qui
vont dans l'enseignement agricole ne
vont pas devenir agriculteurs alors là
on a par ailleurs un travail à faire de
faire en sorte que dans l'enseignement
agricole
ça permet d'accéder aussi à des métiers
d'agriculteurs mais on a besoin de
salariés dans le milieu agricole on a
besoin de gens qui travaillent dans les
exploitations dans les industries
agroalimentaire ce qui nécessite qu'on
travaille d'ailleurs et qu'on fasse une
œuvre collective de valoriser les
métiers de l'agroalimentaire quand vous
avez des jeunes qui vous expliquent qui
n'osent pas dire que leurs parents
travaillent dans des abattoirs comme
s'il faisait un métier honteux on a un
problème dans ce pays
on a besoin de gens qui travaillent dans
les industries agroalimentaires il y a
pas de métiers honteux mais si vous
passez votre temps à dire ça pas vous
pardon je visais personne mais si on
passe son temps à dénigrer les métiers
on attira pas dans les métiers et
dernier élément dans la dans la
réflexion qu'on doit avoir sur
l'enseignement agricole il faut qu'on de
plus en plus les gens qui viennent à
l'enseignement récolte sont des gens qui
ne sont pas issus du milieu agricole et
plus encore parfois pas issus du milieu
rural
et on a un effort y compris dans les
innovations pédagogiques il confie dans
la communication qu'on a à faire pour
parler à ces populations qui ne sont pas
issues du milieu rural et pas issus du
milieu école parce que le renouvellement
des générations ça va être un
renouvellement de gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs mais qui viennent dans le
secteur agricole parce qu'ils y trouvent
du sens
parce qu'il trouve ça me fait du coup la
phrase de conclusion sans le vouloir
mais parce qu'il trouve que nourrir les
gens
assurer la qualité des productions
prendre sa place dans la transition
écologique c'est un beau métier et donc
c'est là dessus qu'il faut qu'on
travaille pour faire en sorte qu'on
assure le renouvellement des générations
merci à toutes et à tous de cette de ce
premier échange et merci monsieur le
Président de votre patience temporel
bien monsieur le ministre merci pour vos
réponses c'est vrai qu'on a débordé mais
c'est un sujet qui nous passionne et
merci pour vos réponses très très
complètes juste pour vous informer chers
collègues avant de clore le programme de
la semaine prochaine je vous rappelle
que mardi 27 nous avons à 14h en salle
Victor Hugo une audition à huit clos qui
est commune avec la commission de la
défense et de la commission des affaires
étrangères de Monsieur Sébastien Lecornu
et de Monsieur Roland Lescure et de mes
yeux Olivier Becht sur les rapports
annuels du Gouvernement au Parlement sur
les exportations par la France
d'armement et de bien à double usage à
17h nous aurons le plaisir de recevoir
ici Jean-Noël barreau ministre délégué
en charge de la transition numérique et
des télécommunication
le mercredi 28 à 9h30 je vous propose
une table ronde sur l'impact de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie sur les
entreprises avec différents
représentants une convocation va vous
partir probablement demain matin et à
20h en visioconférence nous
auditionnerons Monsieur Jean-François
caraco ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
chargées des Outre-mer je vous remercie
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée et à
très bientôt